3x
4x
5x
Du hast nicht ein bisschen tung, oder?
W duplic carried father people.
Der andere Ehemann hat sow sulphur,
aber so weit rien.
Genau so ist es für mich.
Why are you all threatening dad,
if he stitches mach insane and
causes mysterious broads?
Did you change anything?
Ja?
so da bin ich ja es wird mal zeit ich brauche wieder ein paar sachen bei amazon und ich
habe mir gedacht dass es immer eine exzellente gelegenheit dass wir ein bisschen schwätzen
können und ich mache naja was sinnvolles kann man es jetzt nicht nennen ich mache was
was ich eben machen muss so als erstes was willst du haben ich kaufe ich kaufe einen
sub so als erstes bevor wir amazon dropship reseller genau ich dropship reseller twitch
subscriptions und weeps du hättest gern einen 4 in out usb switch achso quasi so eine art kvm
switch oder was oder wie so das wollte ich jetzt sage ja ich habe von der halben stunde
massive nudel gefuttert ich muss jetzt aufpassen dass ich nicht einpenne während ich hier am
stream bin der aktuelle ist trashed ja das wie war das wer billig kauft kauft zweimal
aber er weiß ja nicht ob der billig war ja es wirklich kurz kurz kurz kurz vor bed aber
gerade richtig richtig drei teller voll drei es waren eigentlich waren es nicht zwei es
waren drei aber nicht voll zwei teller war voll und dann noch die reste pepo fett ich
habe trotzdem nicht zugenommen dreimal triple triple pepo fett genau das wollte ich jetzt
am anfang sagen ach ja bevor wir anfangen mit einkauf muss ich euch was erzählen da
weiß ich nicht genau ob ich das im stream machen kann ich habe neues notebook bekommen
von der arbeit und das ist ein microsoft ich habe es jetzt leider nicht hier das ist unten
noch im rucksack das ist ein microsoft surface book surface book 4 vielleicht kann das sein
alter das ist ja richtig teuer der krempel dachte die haben uns irgendwas billiges gekauft
naja gut das ist das schwankt das schwankt ja ja so ein teil ist das hier so mit stift
und so nebendran total total hängen geblieben eigentlich brauche ich werde ich nie benutzen
zumindest ich glaube dass ich weiß nicht ob wir das im stream machen ich müsste das mal
linux technisch einrichten und ich bin mir unschlüssig oder ich weiß noch nicht wie
gut das mit archlinux funktioniert ist im prinzip ist es egal ob es archlinux ist aber
bei the way arch arch by the way by the way arch kann genauso gut ubuntu sein ich weiß
nicht wie gut das hat drauf funktioniert ich habe mir überlegt ob wir das nicht im stream
zusammen machen das ding ist nur ich weiß nicht inwieweit die firma das customized hat
so dass dort logo und name und so erscheinen vielleicht mache ich das auch besser nicht
im stream stripes wollen lang nicht wieso du warst doch erst letztens da oder oder bringe
ich das mit das kann auch sein dass jetzt mit dem discord durcheinander bringen aber
dankeschön für den sub linux surface moment kann ich nicht einfach den ubuntu drauf klatschen
oder archlinux oder irgendwas muss es muss es ernsthaft ein linux kernel für surface
devices sein auch kommen warum braucht es wieder so ein extra wurscht evga trennt sich
vor den video das habe ich gelesen heute morgen warum brauchst du dafür einen extra
spezial kernel laufen die normalen so schlecht oder was
ist das ist das nur gerätetreiber das juckt mich ja alles nicht das brauche ich alles
nicht das also ich brauche ok das keyboard brauche ich touchpad für die mouse tablet
mode brauche ich net touch screen brauche ich net pen brauche ich nicht wifi brauche
ich lte brauche ich nicht bluetooth brauche ich nicht speakers brauche ich nicht buttons
brauche ich brauche alles nicht das ding soll afk bei mir auf der arbeit stehen als jump
nenne ich wirklich als jump rechner für sachen die halt anderweitig nicht gehen so und ich
brauche nix davon ich will das gar nicht als mobiles gerät verwenden ich probiere es mal
mit einem stockkernel weil das wird das wird sonst zu eklig wird custom rumgefuddelt xeito
dankeschön für den sub ja habe ich mir gestern down down geloaded wie das die boomer sagen
würden mit down geloaded wer das nicht kennt das ist ein heavy metal rythmus game ja das
wollte ich mir angucken das habe ich mir schon gekauft und runter geladen wie viele tabs
habe ich auch noch nicht das reicht noch nicht ich habe hier noch tabs auf und wenn das immer
noch nicht reicht ich habe noch eine vm auf ein metal rythmus fps genau so ich habe noch
eine vm auf weil man die einschalten irgendwann wenn die geladen ist dann habe ich da auch
noch tabs auf weil also unter unter 100 tabs ist eigentlich amateurhaft weiß ich wie ihr
das seht wie viel ram ja ich sind auch ein paar tabs ich kann es mir immer nicht merken
ob 16 oder 32 sind 32 davon sind aktuell 17,7 belegt aber nicht durch die tabs sondern wahrscheinlich
zum größten teil durch die vm ja ich kann mir immer nicht merken ob 32 oder 16 das liegt
glaube ich daran weil ich den rechner mit 16 gekauft habe und irgendwann nochmal was
schon das neue video zu thema ingame kreu von ztf magazine nö gewinnen die der sache
irgendwas neues ab ich kann das thema nämlich langsam nicht mehr hören
nee das ist blöd das will ich nicht als die wort enden ja das kommt schon ist es so ist
das genau da ist das gehirn nicht genug ausgelastet wenn wir unter 100 tabs ist weil
stell euch mal vor wo kommen wir denn dahin wenn ich jetzt hier sehen könnte welches
was ist das würde ich ja direkt was finden guck mal wenn ich jetzt sage hey ich suche
ich suche das das youtube video wo wir letztens angefangen haben zu gucken da muss ich muss
wir hier oben drüber gehen ansonsten fordert das das gehirn nicht genug
das mock was der ist weg wirklich das smoke clip ist weg ich habe den nicht gelöscht
nee ich glaube ich weiß was ich weiß was ich eher glaube derjenige der den clip gemacht
hat derjenige der den clip gemacht hat wurde gebannt oder hat sein account gelöscht wer
von weiß noch jemand wer den clip gemacht hat ich habe keine ahnung aber wir können
doch können wir nicht immer schief gucken da wurde gebannt schenors schenors fünfter
account small smoke xx hans hat den gemacht guck mal siehst du siehst du wie gut das archiv
ist wie gut das archiv ist weil der clip funktioniert immer schief noch massive six hat der archiversteller
also wer hat den erstellt den clip xx hans xx hans gucken wir mal ob es dir noch gibt
es xx hans noch xx hans ist immer noch da dann hat er tatsächlich den clip gelöscht
der möchte nicht mehr mit so peinlichen streams wie bei mir in verbindung gebracht werden
kann ich auch verstehen nix wie weg genau archiv besser weird champ hans vielleicht kann man
nur eine spezielle anzahl an clips speicher nee oder nee das kann nicht sein das wäre
bescheuert wenn die dinger irgendwann überschrieben werden so ring buffer mäßig nee das wäre
bescheuert das glaube ich nicht das ist ja auch nicht so als würde so ein clip irgendwie
wahnsinnig viel speicher fressen das ist ja letztendlich erst mal nur irgendwelche verknüpfungen
wie die das unten drunter mit videos machen keine ahnung wahrscheinlich haben die eh
das wott und schneiden das dann raus und speichern es irgendwo als neues video file
ach keine ahnung wie die das machen unter der haube zumindest haben die amazon cloud
im rücken da kann eigentlich nix schiefgehen ja ich weiß nicht genau wie sie es machen
vielleicht ist es auch die original datei und es spult dann unter der haube vor oder
sowas ich weiß nicht wie genau clips funktionieren tatsächlich immer schief alles funktioniert
nicht weil man erst auf die startseite muss und die roten nur oft über die startseite
funktionieren wenn es darüber auslöst das problem hatte ich auch schon mal das ist wird
das ist weird champ du wolltest bachelor arbeit schreiben wir das schreibt immer mal deine
bachelor über was schreibst du deine bachelor arbeit lasst uns mal daran teilhaben the pet
dankeschön für den sub und eben habe ich noch irgendeinen übersehen er hat noch subscribt
ich habe schon gesehen habe ich noch mir war es so als hätte ich ja genau ich habe noch
was übersehen jeder war noch art sie dankeschön massive subscriptions hier alles nicht gesehen
vielleicht gibt es ein timeout wenn ich weiter schreibe genau
jetzt sind sie alle hier ich glaube ich mache jetzt doch ein paar tabs zu weil eine sache
ist wirklich blöd ich erkenne überhaupt nicht mehr was ich hier für tabs auf hat moment
wir müssen mal kurz gucken also ja üblicher blick auf battlefield spieler zahlen okay
sind schlecht spieler zahlen von new world sind auch noch schlecht wer hätte das gedacht
mein auto brauche auch nicht die waage die waage lasse ich mal auf kam immer gut kurz
zeigen zwischendurch ach ja gibt es eigentlich respiratory piles wieder das können wir gerade
mal abchecken wahrscheinlich nicht würde mich sehr wundern wenn es wieder respiratory
piles gibt so man sieht immer noch nicht alles sieht man jetzt alles was das das hier auch
noch zu machen ich sehe immer noch nicht alles ok jetzt wird es langsam ok mal schnell gucken
was was trendet auf github uninteressant uninteressant uninteressant uninteressant und warum ist
es alles dort nett also weil ok langweilig dort nett kenne ich doch das meiste schon
was da trendet auf clear language china chinesen zeug china chinesen zeug keine ahnung krypto
scam zeugs eine note taking application dass das problem immer noch nicht gelöst ist ist
mir ein absolutes rätsel die menschheit baut sein an beginn der zeit note taking applications
und es gibt immer noch keine gescheite pen pot das kenne ich das ist wohl eine figma alternative
das habe ich gestern in einem video gesehen gucken ob das was taugt get started it's free
lul account ja weil figma wurde von adobe gefickt sozusagen und jetzt hat sich das
erledigt surreal db da habe ich auch ein video drüber gesehen das ist neue datenbank die
angeblich alles können soll können wird schauen wir mal in fünf jahren ob es das dann immer
noch gibt aber natürlich ob wir justly play singly fast written in rust kannst du eine
note taking application empfehlen ja tatsächlich das da finde ich gut weil es clients hat und
das finde ich auch gut wobei das hier für open source verfechter nix ist das hier hat
den vorteil du hast apps für alle smartphone plattformen für desktop für mac für linux
alpha windows desktop windows desktop linux desktop mac und die haben integration mit
native notifications also kannst du auch in terminen setzen und das kriegst du deine
nachricht geschickt hier weiß ich nicht mal was es sein soll sms boom china chinesen zeug
ansible pock der weite guck mal die leute sind so unfähig aufgetappt die wissen nicht
mal wie man pock richtig schreibt ich mein twitch weiß wie man pock richtig schreibt
garantiert nicht so und eine game engine alles klar gut aber mal alles dicht hier und erhofft
dass er wieder ein bisschen was sehe so jetzt sollte ich ein bisschen was erkennen so alles
klar kann bahn bord so agiles zeug da das ist nix für uns wir skalieren schon horizontal
und diagonal da braucht man nicht auch noch kann bahn bord wir sind im dauer sprint da
braucht man sowas nicht sprint sind eh unsinnig man kann einfach die ganze zeit rennen
soll jeder machen soll jeder machen benutzen was was ihm gefällt netz noch was das kenne
ich nicht heute ich habe gestern ich muss es jetzt einfach mal sagen ich habe gestern
eines der cringe ich das gucken wir nicht zusammen an ich muss jetzt einfach mal los
werden weil ich mich weil es mal wieder das level von cringe absolut auf neue ebenen gehoben
hat ich habe gestern auf youtube ein video geguckt mehr oder weniger zufällig bin ich
da drauf gekommen durch ein anderes video da ging es drum da war freund und freundin
auf dem klo also das war eine talkshow die heißt auf dem klo euch kann das war das war
so cringe alter ich egal ich fange jetzt gar nicht davon an alter ich es gibt es gibt es
gibt echt videos das ist talk formate wo man echt bei jedem satz denkt meine gute leute
haltet doch einfach die knappe wir müssen in der welt unbedingt alles mitteilen ja ja
ist egal vergesst ja egal was wollte ich eigentlich ganz am anfang des streams erzählen ich wollte
irgendwas sagen bevor wir anfangen bei amazon zu gucken müssen wir noch aber ich habe schon
wieder vergessen was das war ich sollte mir ich sollte mir so was vielleicht aufschreiben
auf was haben wir denn hier noch alles im im shop im im im basket liegen ein sfp plus kabel
ich glaube das brauche ich tatsächlich immer noch ein 48 volt netzteil da habe ich eins
das brauche ich aber tatsächlich auch noch den wasserkocher habe ich schon das brauche
ich net eine säge habe ich mittlerweile auch das brauche ich auch nicht warum habe ich
jetzt auf einmal vier sachen drin sind plus drei ach ich habe das kabel doppelt ja das
ist keine schlechte idee sollte ich vielleicht machen wobei ich das kabel wahrscheinlich
eher einmal in zwei meter und einmal vielleicht warum ist 0,2 meter teurer als zwei meter
was ist das wieder für blödsinn kein smarten wasserkocher doch ich habe in der küche mittlerweile
einige sachen smart in anführungsstrichen gemacht nämlich einfach mit einer schaltbaren
steckdose die meisten smarten geräte sind nicht smart das sind geräte haben sie in
wlan in esp verpasst oder in wlan chip verpasst der für diese geräteklasse komplett unsinnig
ist weil du nicht machen kannst dran was du machen willst richtig richtig dämlich und
wisst ihr was ich auch wisst ihr was ich auch raus bekommen habe gestern kann sich einer
noch einmal heizungs dashboard erinnern das war sich eigentlich schon seit einem jahr
oder so nicht mehr verwende wo noch nicht mal mehr daten drin sind ok jetzt hat sich
ausgeheizungs dashboard zumindest weil ich direkt in meinem rack das verkabeln will und
mein rack ist ja nur ganz kleines ich will quasi vom switch an den server hinten dran
erreichen 0,2 wenn ich kann auch ein meter nehmen und es einfach aufgerollt haben ich
habe heizschamp 2.0 ist ist aktiv zumindest was ich eigentlich sagen wollte meine heizung
ja für alle die es nicht mitbekommen haben die kann man auslesen mit so einem spezial
kabel vom hersteller oder man kann sich so ein kabel selbst bauen sieht dann so aus
steckt man da vorne rein auf der anderen seite per usb dann geht man auf github lädt
sich diese software hier runter und dann kann man seine heizung auslesen ist egal will ich
will ich mich jetzt gar nicht so sehr darüber auslassen aber wisst ihr was ich rausgekriegt
habe der hersteller dachte sich wohl die leute können selbst ihre sachen auslesen ohne unsere
app zu verwenden und ohne unseren cloud service zu verwenden und da haben sich die ganzen
manager dort gedacht ungefähr so war der gedankengang der manager bei denen und da haben die gesagt
nein das schaffen wir ab das gibt es in zukunft nicht mehr und die neuen heizungen von denen
haben jetzt diese opto link schnitt stelle nicht mehr dafür eine integrierte wlan addon
platte die wahrscheinlich 800 euro kostet wenn das ding mal verreckt im endeffekt ist
es wahrscheinlich einfach ein esp aufgelötet auf irgendeiner leeren platte den dann eingesteckt
wird und cdox dankeschön für den sub und haben wlan modul integriert haben kein opto
link anschluss mehr und du kriegst die sachen nur noch und jetzt kommt es nicht nur über
die offizielle app oder sowas raus nein du musst die offizielle cloud anbindung von
denen auch noch verwenden das heißt du musst im wlan du musst im keller wlan haben und
dann musst du quasi deine daten erst mal ins internet zum hersteller hochladen damit
du deine daten später dann wieder runter ziehen kannst von dort zu dir also richtig
hängen geblieben ich weiß nicht wer diesen ganzen herstellern immer so ins hirn scheiß
ich meine ich weiß es irgendwelche super krassen bvl stonks leute sind das aber ich
weiß nicht warum die alle so wie unfreundlich kann man sich nennen wie nennen wie soll
man das nennen so anti consumer sind mit allem ich verstehe das einfach nicht haben die haben
die angst davor dass die leute vielleicht was aus der heizung auslesen könnten und
dann feststellen oder die qualität ist doch nicht so geil oder ja genau es ist nicht jeder
feifert das kann auch nicht mal jeder machen ist doch ist doch nicht schlimm dann macht
es halt nicht jeder wichtig ist dass es geht und die sachen mit der cloud das ging ja vorher
auch schon diese die hätten diese stelle einfach nicht abschaffen müssen und wisst ihr was
dann immer als nächstes kommt ich weiß übrigens gar nicht ob das geld kostet wollen wir
das mal das gucken wir jetzt mal nach also falls es kein geld kostet in zwei jahren
kostet das dann abo gebühren für die cloud schnittstelle 100 pro es versuchen mittlerweile
so viele hersteller so die auf diesen zug aufzuspringen bei meinem auto ist es genauso
drei monate sind diese juke nicht drei monate drei jahre sind diese juke connect services
dabei und danach musste irgendwie nochmal 160 euro im jahr bezahlen oder sowas ich hoffe
halt bis dahin gibt es was gibt es die back interfaces und sowas zum auslesen ja genau
bei manchen autos brauchst du ein aber dass deine heizung funktioniert die schon drin
ist also das ist mittlerweile wirklich absolut die pest oder mittlerweile sagt man zu allem
toxic ja es ist toxic es ist toxic ja die die leute mit ein bisschen durchblick die
sind für open source oder zumindest zumindest leute ich kann es ja verstehen wenn ein hersteller
sagt er möchte seine systeme nicht offenlegen kann ich ja verstehen ja dass sie ihre firmen
nicht auf github pushen wollen und so ok verstehe ich wahrscheinlich würde man einfach mal
sehen wie low iq das ganze zeug programmiert ist aber das verstehe ich ja aber wichtig
ist dass es offene schnittstellen gibt ja dass es entweder mqtt anbindung gibt eine web interface
oder sonst was deswegen habe ich mich auch bei meiner bei meinem ladegerät fürs auto
für dieses ding hier entschieden weil
weil ich brauche das manuell davon
passt mal auf die haben doch tatsächlich ein ladegerät gebaut dass über öffentliche
also öffentlich im internet sind sie nicht dass über schnittstellen verfügt die du
als normalsterblicher abfragen kannst die haben eine web im web im web interface bzw
web schnittstellen mqtt anbindung und und modbus warum nicht immer so warum machen das
nicht einfach alle so muss das sein das finde ich wunderbar so sollen sie das machen können
sie ruhig können sie ruhig alle so machen das war das war für mich der ausschlaggebende
grund übrigens wisst ihr wie die das machen mit dieser in dieser in diesem ladegerät
die haben ich weiß gar nicht ob es ein bild von innen gibt ich hoffe der macht den auf
wahrscheinlich nicht es wäre cool wenn man wenn man da reingucken können ja hier kann
man reingucken außer dass hier irgendeiner verschmort ist und wenn man hier genau guckt
wird man wahrscheinlich feststellen ja wenn man hier genau guckt ein bisschen höher
auflösen wird man wahrscheinlich ein altbekanntes bauteil finden kennt ihr das da oben kommt
euch das da oben irgendwie bekannt vor was da oben steckt was könnte das da oben sein
ein chat was könnte das nur sein das sieht das sieht mir ganz stark nach einem esp 866
note mcu aus so ein ding was wir auch schon mehrfach es können auch in esp 32 sein das
erkennt man nicht genau aber ist das vielleicht erkennt man es wenn das ein bisschen bewegt
wartet mal warte mal hier komm vielleicht komme ich reingucken ja ja guck mal das ist
auf jeden fall esp ich vermute mal anhand der pins es ist sind das doppelte pins oder
einfache pins hier oder doppelte oder einfach ich erkenne es nicht richtig sind das zwei
pins nebeneinander oder ist das ein pin ich muss es mal kurz vergleich hab doch hier
ein liegen ich glaube das sind ein das sind ein pins also dann ist es nur esp 32 also
die machen das die kochen auch alle nur mit wasser aber trotzdem die haben ein ordentliches
gerät gebaut und ohne scheiß wenn dann esp 32 drinne ist ist mir sogar noch viel lieber
wenn die irgendwann mal auf die idee kommen wir supporten das nicht mehr und dann braucht
man wirklich eine firmware update für eine wallbox kann ja sein aus irgendwelchen gründen
da kannst du zumindest entweder selbst was machen oder aber gucken ob es nicht ob es
nicht custom firmware gibt wir gucken mal kurz auf github ob es nicht schon custom firmware
gibt wir flaschen das motor drauf ne mache ich nicht egal zumindest das war eines der
gründe warum ich gesagt habe ich ich hole mir das teil einfach weil dann esp 32 drinne
ist und esp 266 man erkennt es halt nicht richtig das müsste das müsste halt mal einer hätte
mal einer fotografieren müssen hat wieder keiner gecheckt dass es ein esp ist und man
ein ordentliches foto von gemacht na egal ist wurscht zumindest ich fand es cool dass
da im endeffekt eine esp drinne ist nächste woche kommt wahrscheinlich der elektriker
und baut mir den kram endlich ein ja welcher welcher ist es denn welcher von beiden vielleicht
war das erfindet man auch einfach hier ego charger fix esp was kostet der einbau irgendwas
um 300 euro wahrscheinlich allerdings ist nicht nur der einbau sondern muss auch noch
noch noch noch ein kabel legen dahin das ist ok die ha und streams die sind wahrscheinlich
zum nachgucken gar nicht so dolle weil ich habe es oft stream fertig gemacht übrigens
kann ich euch jetzt an der stelle mal zeigen wer hier bei mir im stream war als wir das
home assistant addon gebaut haben und sich jetzt fragt wann gibt es denn das home assistant
addon für den fiat endlich gut hub wupplos auf gut hub das gibt es schon seit ein paar
tagen hier guckt der fiat champ ist am start hat immer schon sieben sterne leute massiv
massiv sternsohr der esp wird doch nicht die einzige der einzige microcontroller darin
sein doch warum nicht was brauchst du bei so einem ladegerät ansonsten noch was da sind
wahrscheinlich ein paar relays drinnen eine sicherung und das dürfte so viel ist da wahrscheinlich
nicht drin mit dem esp wisse die relays schalten und das das war es vermutlich mal stark wüsste
nicht wozu da noch mehr noch mehr controller drin sein sollten naja zumindest also dass
ich jetzt hochgeladen vor drei tagen sieht man ja auch hier seitdem hat sich bild übrigens
das ist das beste bild script also so ein high IQ build script habt ihr noch nicht gesehen
soll ich euch mal zeigen passt mal auf
ich weiß gar nicht warum ich das überhaupt noch drinne habe das macht einfach gar nix
ich glaube das hatte ich am anfang mal angelegt dass ich in meinen repo pushen konnte und
versionsnummer hochzählen konnte und so alles in einem hat mir gedacht brauche ich ja gar
nicht mehr ja leute backfreie software so sieht es aus wobei immerhin je nachdem wo
das ausführt kann sogar sein dass es das nicht gibt zumindest also werden halbwegs
neuen fiat hat und home assistant verwendet für seine heim automatisierung kann sich
mein addon mal angucken das einzige was ihr braucht ist halt ein auto was es unterstützt
also sprich irgendeinen halbwegs neuen fiat mit uconnect services steht aber auch alles
da guckt mal ich habe mir wirklich mühe gegeben mit der readme oder ich habe ich habe screenshots
drinnen ich habe erklärungen drinnen was man vorher braucht was es für features hat
was nicht funktioniert was es auf gar keinen fall geben wird wie man das ganze installiert
wie die options aussehen und was man einstellen muss nicht ubisoft connect uconnect ist irgendwas
von fiat für web services weil ich hasse immer github repos ohne screenshots also ist
insofern aktiv maintained das bis alles drinne ist was ich haben will und aktuell fehlen
mir noch remote commands weil ich mag keine repos in denen keine screenshots drin sind
kennt ihr das ihr seht in der übersicht von github ein projekt und denkt euch das hört
sich aber ganz cool an und es ist halt irgendwas mit dem web interface oder so und ihr macht
das auf und dann stehen dann 5000 zeilen wie geil das ist und nicht ein screenshot ich
bin der mein so ein screenshot rein zu packen das das vermittelt einfach so ein bisschen
besseren eindruck vom ganzen vom ganzen vom ganzen projekt als einfach nur text was ich
mir gekauft habe ich habe mir einen neuen fiat 500 e gekauft und ich habe einfach mal
mein dashboard fotografiert wo ich halt ein paar sachen geerdet habe wo man gucken kann
ja standort kannst du gucken und zeug egal das ist jetzt also wer ausprobieren will
ich habe es jetzt gepusht auf github wer dem ganzen natürlich einen stern geben will
was hier übrigens jemand gerade gemacht hat sehr nice ich freue mich über jeden stern
in gewisser weise promoted das da das addon auch ein bisschen ich habe mir überlegt ob
ich nicht vielleicht doch besser als home assistant integration hätte bauen sollen
als addon aber dann müsste ich in python machen dann läuft es in process vom home assistant
ich weiß ich glaube so ist das eigentlich besser stern für stern trade genau aber sub
for sub was ist das dafür ein emote was denn welches das da das ist ein auto oder was
meinst du das da das ist keck alu keck keck alu wie teuer war das logo da mussten die
fiver in der drei tage für arbeiten für dieses logo hier das da das ist ganz normales
emoji ganz normales emoji so dass hier ist das ganz normales ganz normales emote ja
leute also für dieses logo warum nicht keckel mehr weil keine twitch emotes unterstützt
werden normalerweise auf webseiten ich finde es auch nicht gut dass twitch emotes nicht
ein allgemeiner offener standard sind in jeder browser unterstützen muss aber leider ist
es so twitch emotes funktionieren auf den selbsten auf den wenigsten seiten es sei denn
du hast zusatz addons und das hat ja kaum einer also für dieses logo mussten die fiver
in der fünf tage schuft mir weiß der hintergrund wissen warum das ding überhaupt ein logo
hat das ding hat ein logo damit das addon nicht so kacke im addon store aussieht ohne
bild das ist der einzige grund wie ist der fiat so als daily ja er bringt mich von a
nach b wobei ich noch nicht mal daily fahre also ich finde es gut also ich ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich war ja am anfang ein bisschen unschlüssig ob ich mir ein elektroauto kaufen soll oder
nicht ich hätte mir normalerweise auch kein elektroauto gekauft ich habe ich habe mir
das elektroauto oder zwei zwei bedingungen gekauft ja erstens es muss dieses jahr noch
klappen wegen förderung ja das darf insgesamt nicht so teuer sein und es muss eins sein
was mir von der von der technik her gefällt verbrauch wie teuer ist einmal voll machen
reichweite also reichweite hat er maximal sowas zumindest sagt er das ja ich habe ich
habe so nicht ausprobiert ich glaube bis zu es steht immer wenn es 100 prozent ist steht
glaube ich da 185 kilometer ob es das wirklich packt so wie ich war wahrscheinlich nicht
weil er sagt mir immer eco score ist ganz ganz schlecht bei mir also ich fahre anscheinend
nicht sonderlich effizient also er sagt 285 kilometer standardmäßig in da sieht man ja
auch hier guckt hier war er nicht voll ja also etwa 84 prozent ist er der meinung 200 217
kilometer so 285 kilometer ist er da habe ich 185 285 285 kilometer ist er der meinung wenn
er voll geladen ist packt er so ansonsten er beschleunigt sehr schnell was wirklich
nice ist ich habe teilweise richtig fette karren an der ampel hinter mir stehen und so
die ersten sachen so bis 50 ist er halt allen weg gefahren das ist jetzt die sind da ganz
klein im spiegel noch die sich quasi kaum noch flutscht richtig ich meine ansonsten
ich weiß nicht ob 8 8,5 sekunden von 0 auf 100 gut sind wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich
versus irgendwelche fetten karren aber zumindest so die ersten paar so die ersten so die ersten
50 kmh beim anfahren da ist er so sag ich da ist eigentlich selten irgendjemand hinten
dran wie ist die förderung bei dir die ist da schon dabei die muss ich also die wurde
ja schon mal abgezogen das ist dann nichts was ich beantragen muss aber es war halt insgesamt
schon billiger also ich habe 25.200 euro bezahlt das einzige was meinem friseur dafür dazu
eingefallen ist wir hatten es von wir hatten es von irgendwie von den von von autos das
einzige was meinem friseur dazu eingefallen ist alter da hättest ja schon amg für fahren
können ich will aber eigentlich kein amg fahren wie gesagt ich habe in 4 500 e gekauft so
da wollte ich zwar nicht drauf raus aber wenn es da noch fragen gibt haut rein ja aktuell
ist das noch neu und interessant für mich und ich bin auch noch am rumbasteln jetzt
kenne ich mich noch aus das heißt nicht kann sein ich das in dem jahr schon wieder alles
vergessen habe er hat halt für mich sehr viele funktionen die ich so gar nicht kannte
ich meine ihr kennt beziehungsweise leute die öfters im stream wissen was ich vorher
für ein auto hatte und da sind ja wirklich welten dazwischen mein altes auto war baujahr
ich weiß ich glaube 2001 oder 2002 hatte hatte ja und das hatte einfach gar nichts
an technik das hatte analoge ans das das war quasi noch old school auto noch bevor computer
und controller in autos eingebaut wurden da ist da ist wirklich also vorher hatte ich
ein ja auch in grün so ein teil hatte ich vorher da war nichts elektronisch irgendwie
du musstest auch noch kurbeln am fenster und so was also sprich es war komplett es war
einfach nur metall und analoge technik und für mich ist es quasi ein riesen unterschied
von dem auto zu dem aktuellen weil mein altes auto hat halt einfach gar nichts das das das
war ein gehäuse mit motor analoge technik und mechanik und und analoge ans das hatte
nichts das das das technologisch highendigste in meinem auto war das radio und das war auch
in heutigen standards wirklich kacke so und im vergleich zu dem jetzigen ist es wirklich
komplett andere welt was der hat alles mögliche drinne was ich was ich gar nicht gar nicht
wusste ja der kann dir der erkennt straßenschilder und warnt dich dann wenn du zu schnell fährst
und solche sachen wo ich mir so denke ach guck mal was das ding alles kann nein mehr
braucht für die sitzheizung kein abo aber ich würde mich wundern wenn er eine sitzheizung
hätte ich habe zumindest nichts davon gesehen nicht der friseur nicht der friseur lane assist
hatte auch es hat mich schon manchmal verwirrt ein bisschen wobei dass ich erst ab 60 aktiviert
da liegen 20 jahre dazwischen das stimmt aber ich glaube die 20 jahre davor und die 20 jahre
jetzt danach wären kein so großer unterschied gewesen also hätte ich mir 1980 oder 2000 auto
gekauft wenn die unterschiede nicht so krass gewährt also moment also das auto was ich hatte
es gab sicherlich 2000 auch schon bessere fortschrittlichere autos also hätte ich mir
1980 in auto gekauft und oder dann 2000 den den agila da wäre wahrscheinlich nicht so viel
unterschied gewesen und zwischen heute und 2040 ist wahrscheinlich auch kein so krasser unterschied
mehr als zwischen 2000 und 2022 oder 2020 und 2000 2001 und 2021 ich meine die autos sind ja
im prinzip von damals von von blechkisten mit mechanik und analoge technik zu ziemlich viel
computer kram auf vierrädern geworden deswegen also das ist riesen das wirklich riesen unterschied
und ich bin immer wieder überrascht ich finde da täglich noch neue sachen ich habe jetzt
beispielsweise erst gestern festgestellt dass ich am am lenkrad ein steuerkreuz habe wo ich
verschiedene hat oder wie nennt man so verschiedene display elemente durchschalten kann ich weiß
noch nicht genau warum ich das machen will aber das geht keine ahnung ich weiß ich weiß
beispielsweise nicht mal was alle knöpfe am lenkrad überhaupt machen also es ist nice also
tatsächlich ich bin normalerweise kein großartiger autofan und autos gehen mir komplett am arsch
vorbei aber ich muss sagen das gefällt mir ich kann es jetzt zum ersten mal nachvollziehen
ich kann es jetzt zum ersten mal nachvollziehen wenn leute immer so sofort auto emotionen und
blablabla reden das ist jetzt einfach mal wirklich was interessant das neu ist tolle
übergabe ich glaube nicht dass eine übergabe normalerweise beinhaltet dass du jeden einzelnen
knopf und jede dreifache funktion davon erklärt kriegst will ich auch gar nicht ich will gar
nicht dass mir das irgend so ein typ erklärt ich brauche die basics und den rest gucke
ich mir alleine an weil ganz ehrlich ich mache das eh so wie ich es für am besten halte
und nicht wie mir das irgendjemand erzählt zum beispiel in der werkstatt haben die auch
immer gesagt ja wenn man wenn man fertig wenn man fertig fahren ist soll man auf den auf
den park modus switchen und die handbremse rein machen was komplett bescheuert ist das
macht das auto komplett von alleine du musst einfach nur ausschalten der macht automatisch
park modus an und handbremse an und noch besser wenn du einfach nur den schlüssel rausnimmst
also wenn du auf parken parken machst du nimmst einfach nur den schlüssel und gehst raus
dann macht er auch alles aus also eigentlich musst du gar nichts machen außer ausschalten
so nein ich hab nicht die caprio variante ich hab das ding hier guck mit der extra tür
das teil was kostet einmal aufladen das könnte man eigentlich ausrechnen ich mein das ist
ein 42 kilowattstunden akku jetzt müssen wir mal gucken was die kilowattstunde kostet
und dann mal 42 naja wird schon ein bisschen was kosten aber es ist höchstwahrscheinlich
billiger als an die tankstelle zu fahren aktuell die extra tür ist nur an einer seite ja schädler
wir haben so viele keck emote guck mal wir haben wir haben zu viele noch mehr keck emote
geht nicht wir haben nahezu alles an keck emote was es gibt zeigt noch mal paar bilder
please so sieht das ding aus guck sie einfach bei fiat auf der seite an da kannst du sogar
3d drum herum schwenken und sowas seit wann ich den gehabt hab oh das weiß ich gar nicht
mehr genau das ist auf jeden fall lange her das ist ganz lange her
ich hab's bisher nicht großartig ausprobiert ich hab's einmal ausprobiert absichtlich
und letztens als ich zum wandern gefahren bin hat er einmal gegriffen da war ich anscheinend
ein bisschen zu nah an der spur wie war die lieferzeit von dem teil die war nicht vorhanden
weil das ein vorführeauto ist und ich hab gesagt sie nimmt es gleich mit also gleich
mit paar tage später habe ich dann abgeholt nachdem das mit der anmeldung und so alles
durch war ne gerade nicht dementsprechend kann ich dir auch nix empfehlen
ich hab das ich hab das noch nicht ausprobiert also man kann angeblich mit dem ding geschwindigkeit
einstellen und abstand zum vordermann einstellen und dann kannst du quasi wenn du auf der auto
mal längere zeit geradeaus fährst mehr oder weniger ohne lenken fahren du musst bloß
ich hab wie gesagt ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert du musst bloß ab und zu mal die hände aufs
lenkrad machen weil der sonst nervt was aber auch ok ist weil ganz im ernst ohne hände
aufs lenkrad das ist dann schon fast kokona style wo mal irgend so ein typ hintergegangen
ist im auto und seine kaffeemaschine angemacht hat und danach den auto hersteller verklagt
hat weil nirgendswo ein hinweis stand dass man während der fahrt nicht hinten sich
einen kaffee machen gehen soll das ist halt das ist halt typische typische kokona logik
ja das muss nicht sein es geht aus irgendwelchen gründen gerade um ein auto ich weiß auch
nicht wie wir da drauf gekommen sind gut ich meine wir sind im einkaufen stream eigentlich
wollte ich heute was einkaufen ich hab letztens ein auto gekauft zählt ja auch irgendwo dazu
so amazon amazon haben wir die ganzen kreml hierzu wir sind irgendwie von meiner heizung
auf mein ladegerät auf mein auto gekommen und dass das ladegerät in esp 32 sp 28 66
drin hat was ziemlich was ziemlich ist wobei warum eigentlich würde es genauso auch bauen
aber guck mal da ist ein bisschen was durchgegriffen das sieht ungesund aus das ist das ist nicht
gut was ist die beste lösung wlan lan in verschiedene räume zu bekommen kabel kanäle
an wand decke dlan kabel durch die bude am rand einfach durch also ganz ehrlich die beste
lösung ist ein kabel durch durch die wand und die decke kabel ist prinzipiell das beste
nee nicht wirklich ich weiß was es ist und wir hatten testweise sowas auch mal für viele
kleine daten im einsatz in der erprobung wir haben sie wirklich verwendet nee keine ahnung
also ohne scheiß kabel ist das beste was du machen kannst also wenn du die möglichkeit
das kabel zu legen macht kabel und wie versteckt man das kabel dann wenn es vom router quer
durch einen raum geht tja gar nicht wozu warum willst du das verstecken was ist das problem
an kabel ansonst legst halt an der wand lang oder aber wenn du eh schon durch die decke
willst ja dann mach halt das loch in der decke an der stelle wo der router ist vielleicht
hast du eine zwischendecke also es ist ganz einfach du musst gewichten was dir am wichtigsten
ist ja ist es für dich wichtig dass du technisch die beste lösung hast ist es für dich wichtig
dass es möglichst billig ist ist es für dich wichtig dass es möglichst einfach ist ist
es für dich wichtig dass es möglichst gut aussieht am ende da musst du die beste kombination
darauf nehmen wenn du beispielsweise sehr viel wert darauf legst dass nichts an kabel
zu sehen ist und du auch kein aufwand haben willst dann ja dann machen stellen wlan router
hin oder mach irgendwas mit dlan oder so das beste aus technischer sicht ist nach wie
vor und das wird es auch für immer sein kabel entweder kannst du das kabel oben lang machen
eventuell kannst du auch mal gucken ob es noch alte telefonleitungen gibt die du verwenden
kannst zwischen den räumen die du miteinander verbinden willst wobei man sagen muss da
brauchst du noch ein bisschen mehr als dass du kannst nicht einfach das netzwerkabel als
telefonkabel stöpseln nein habe ich noch nicht das steht für nächstes jahr an aber
ich fürchte nächstes jahr wird das nächste mal alle aktuell darauf wert legen und ich
habe mir jetzt so überlegt ich werde wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen warten ja wenn so was ist
auch nicht verkehrt genau also ich habe mir überlegt ich werde wahrscheinlich dann doch
noch ein bisschen länger warten eigentlich wollte ich mich nächstes jahr mal damit beschäftigen
bzw. mit beschäftigt habe ich ja schon wollte ich nächstes jahr mal gucken vielleicht auch
mal irgendeinen der sich damit auskennt sich das dach anschauen lassen ich habe ja auch
schon mal so eine planung gemacht welche dachseite wie viel das ungefähr gibt und was
sich lohnt und so was ungefähr kostet aber ich habe jetzt folgendes überlegt ich werde
wahrscheinlich einfach noch ein bisschen warten weil die dinger werden wahrscheinlich die
nächsten jahre noch deutlich besser werden mit ein bisschen glück auch günstiger aber
worauf ich ja persönlich etwas spekuliere ist dass es die nächsten jahre etwas einfacher
wird sich sowas zu installieren also sprich dass organisatorische und bürokratische hürden
so weit abgebaut sind dass du sowas dir installieren lassen kannst ohne dass du das studieren musst
und das wäre schon mal sehr nice und wenn sich da ein bisschen was tut dann bin ich
der erste der so ein ding bei uns auf dach hat sie sind ja gerade dabei zumindest haben
sie gesagt sie wollen den bürokratischen organisatorischen aufwand für Leute die sich
erneuerbare energien daheim hinstellen wollen verringern was ich auch gut finde aber mal
gucken zwischen dem was erzählt wird und zwischen dem was am ende gemacht wird sie natürlich
immer zwei paar schuhe ich habe mir die gleiche waage gekauft und schon geflasht du kannst
die waage überhaupt nicht flaschen chain load du erzählst da wieder ein zeug die waage
wird überhaupt nicht geflasht exposed tailer erzählt für den blödsinn wie gesagt ich
kann hier nach dem gehen nach dem gehen was angekündigt wird und das wurde zumindest
angekündigt ob das so ist ja oder ob das genauso ist wie breitbandausbau in deutschland
ihr wisst ja moment ihr wisst ja dass seit 2017 also seit fünf jahren 50 mbit für jeden
haushalt drin sind und das inzwischen auch in gigabit gedacht werden muss also wenn auch
keine 50 mbit hat ist eindeutig noch nicht 2018 angekommen
denn das ist ja nichts neues was die anlage war genehmigt was hatten eine solaranlage auf
dem dach die stadtag geklagt die nach dem das sind solche dinger ich habe ein kollege
auf der arbeit der versucht seit vier jahren oder so sowas hin zu bekommen er hat das problem
er wohnt bei uns ja also im alten stadt teil und die sagen nein denkmalschutz du darfst
keine solaranlage aufs dach bauen wo ich mich halt frage was juckt denn das fachwerkhaus
beziehungsweise was juckt denn die optik von diesem haus irgendwie beziehungsweise sieht
man das überhaupt wenn er halt was auf dem dach ist also denkmal schutz finde ich da
immer anzuführen teilweise echt fragwürdig das ist das ist ähnlich wie wenn irgendwo
was gebaut werden soll und dann wird dann hier die was weiß ich grünbauch was weiß
ich grünbauch schnell schnell heuschrecke gefunden und dann kann das natürlich erstmal die nächsten
35 jahre nicht weiter gebaut werden weil die muster brüten cringe wer kein gigabit hat ja so
ist es ich cringe mit ich habe auch noch kein gigabit ah gut so jetzt gucken wir mal bei amazon
rein weil eigentlich wollte ich heute was ist das hier warum ist das fenster so klein
muss man nicht verstehen mal gucken was uns amazon empfiehlt kann ja mal schauen
ich weiß ich weiß eigentlich wollte ich hab habt ihr das mitbekommen ich meine ich habe
da gestern ein video zu gemacht aber das heißt so lange nicht dass sie da mitbekommen hat habt
ihr den uber den uber hack mitbekommen wo irgend ein 18 jähriger also wo irgend ein 18 jähriger
bei uber eingebrochen ist eingebrochen kann so nicht eingebrochen nehmen wo sich ein 18 jähriger
an account erschlichen hat von einem uber mit arbeiter und dann ins interne netzwerk gekommen
ist und von dort weiter zu aws und google cloud es gibt jetzt paar neue news dazu ich war wie
gesagt ich weiß nicht ob das stimmt weil im internet wird viel erzählen wenn der tag lang
ist ich weiß nicht ob das stimmt aber das war kurz gucken hatte nämlich auf twitter was zu
ja genau also der hacker sagt folgendes wir an also hintergrund ist folgendes gewesen die
leute bei uber sind ja auch nicht doof das heißt ja in zwei fakten identifizierung das heißt
irgendjemand hat nicht nur den account und das password geklaut sondern konnte auch die
zwei fakten identifizierung umgehen und jetzt kommt der hit wisst ihr wie er die zwei fakten
identifizierung umgangen hat gar nicht der hat die zwei fakten identifizierung einfach gemacht und
zwar folgendermaßen er hat einfach den mitarbeiter von uber zugespämmt mit zwei fakten
identifizierungsanfragen und dann hat er ihn kontaktiert über whatsapp und hat ihm erzählt
er kommt von von uber it support und hat ihm gesagt wenn er nicht möchte dass er weiter
zugespämmt wird mit zwei fakten identifizierung dann soll er das einfach akzeptieren und dann
hat es akzeptiert und dann ist gut aber ganz im ernst es klingt jetzt total abwegig aber so
abwegig ist das gar nicht überlegt euch doch mal wie viele leute würden denn da wirklich
mitmachen stellt euch mal vor verwendet jemand von euch microsoft zwei fakten identifizierung
oder amazon zwei fakten identifizierung also bei microsoft ich mache so ein beispiel machen wir
was am beispiel von von der microsoft zwei fakten identifizierung da gehst du auf die
webseite bei microsoft gibst ein password eingibt gibt es ein username und password ein und dann
kannst du auswählen was du für einen zweiten faktor verwenden willst sms authenticator app
oder halt smartphone also anruf und stellt euch mal vor es ist nachts es ist samstag nachts um
vier und euch ruft der microsoft support an beziehungsweise diese diese dieser anruf beantworter
dieser microsoft anruf beantworter der sagt dann drücken sie jetzt die raute taste um das zu
bestätigen leute ihr nehmt das telefon ab und wahrscheinlich drückt ihr raute wenn es stelle
ich stelle euch mal vor ihr werdet da nicht nur einmal angerufen ihr werdet 20 mal angerufen
und irgendwann nehmt ihr ab und drückt raute entweder weil ihr so so gewöhnt seid oder weil
ihr keinen bock mehr auf den scheiß habt ich mein ich würde es nicht machen und ihr wahrscheinlich
auch nicht aber ganz im ernst die meisten würden das machen und also so abwegig ist das nicht
ja wollte ich euch wollte ich euch mal zeigen wie gesagt wir wissen wir wissen nicht ob das ob
das stimmt aber ich kann es mir gut vorstellen weil irgendwie muss eine zwei faktor identifizierung
vorbeigekommen sein und das beste ist nachdem er dann die zwei faktor identifizierung überwunden
hat und sich einloggen konnte da konnte er sich auch direkt per vpn verbinden und war dann quasi
direkt im netz von uber und danach hat er das habe ich in meinem video erzählt also wenn es
interessiert wer es noch nicht gesehen hat kann sich das hier angucken danach hat er
powershell skripte gefunden intern auf einem windows share auf einem internen windows share
bei uber hat er powershell skripte gefunden mit admin password kombination für aws und google
cloud und von dort konnte er dann weiter und konnte sich im endeffekt alles mögliche alles
mögliche angucken was die was die so haben ja zum beispiel hier admin esx cluster den uber esx
cluster admin zugriff drauf gehabt also die haben richtig richtig reingeschissen
1,1 petabyte storage ja warum nicht man uber braucht alle bissl bissl storage ja
also ich persönlich mag vpn ja weil vpn so mit abstand das einfachste und angenehmste ist
damit zu arbeiten man muss halt eine gute also eine gute kombination finden warum geht hier mein
browser auf der anderen seite nicht mehr richtig wartet mal kurz so geht das jetzt alles klar ja
muss eine gute kombination finden aus ist benutzbar und ist sicher wirst du mw2 testen
wenn es eine pc beta gibt die man nicht preordern muss wann geht es auf dem pc los
ja pc 22 september das ist nächste woche donnerstag
nee das ist early access am 24 geht's los ich werde es diesmal definitiv nicht dafür preordern
24 ok oder ich preorders und bestellst dann wieder ab das ist auch immer eine gute taktik ja gut das
ist natürlich bescheuert also wenn du vpn mit einem admin user macht der dann auch direkt beim
login überall admin rechte überall hin hat ist natürlich bescheuert man sollte schon davon
ausgehen dass auch leute die sie intern im netzwerk anstöpsel nicht alles machen dürfen
hat es schon mal eine kooperation ja mehrfach allerdings ich glaube die mögen mich nicht
mehr was ich auch verstehen kann weil ich habe gerade den modern warfare multiplayer glaube
ziemlich geflammt aber wer mich definitiv nicht mehr einladen wird wahrscheinlich nie wieder
ist wahrscheinlich ea zu battlefield aber hey was kann ich dafür wenn das spiel so
scheiße geworden ist das ist da kann ich doch nichts für wisst ihr das ist eigentlich total
hängen geblieben ich würde mir wahrscheinlich mehr als ea wünschen dass das ein gutes spiel
wird ja also gutes spiel für mich nicht unbedingt im sinne von ea und ja es war halt scheiße und
was soll ich denn sagen ich meine ich habe ich habe mich äußerst gequält mit den videos ja ich
habe hier ja sponsored video habe ich schon nicht mal guckt mal leute das einzige video ohne
thumbnail sponsored video da habe ich mir richtig mühe gegeben bei dem video alles klare sieben
minuten ich glaube ich habe alles an an hazard zone gameplay was ich aufgenommen habe da irgendwie
reingeverwurstet dass es nicht ganz so langweilig ist also das ist sponsored das ist sponsored das
ist sponsored gewesen und dazwischen habe ich hochgeladen ist das noch battlefield der absturz
von battlefield das hat ihnen nicht so gefallen glaube ich aber gut ich weiß was soll ich machen
was kann ich dafür dass das spiel kacke geworden ist soll ich ernsthaft nichts dazu sagen und ich
habe schon in meinem ersten eindruck video einiges gesagt was nicht so gut ist aber hier hat sich
das dann noch mal gefestigt ja ja so sieht es halt aus ne das machen sie nicht die laden dort nie zu
diesen event früher gab es mal das game changer programm beziehungsweise dass ganz früher gab es
auch wie ist das ron kuh hieß das glaube ich das hat nichts mit diesem mit diesem android tv boxen
hersteller zu tun da war ich ja damals auch in diesem internen creator programm von ea das
war eigentlich eine wirklich coole geschichte damals da haben sie dann verschiedene aufgaben
nicht aufgaben verschiedene jobs gepostet quasi zeigt eine multiplayer runde im neuen dlc und
konnte das hier einreihe fand ich eigentlich eine coole geschichte wurde dann irgendwann abgeschafft
zumindest früher gab es dann halt das danach gab es noch das game changer programm aber
mittlerweile ist es so die laden sich nur noch leute ein die alles abfeiern das habe ich auch
bei diesen events gesehen ich habe schon oft erzählt leute ihr glaubt nicht wie viel dort
rumgeschleimt wurde also es wurde schon auf den vorherigen events krass rumgeschleimt und
die games waren aber halt noch irgendwie recht nice wenn viel eins hat es bei mir schon so ein
bisschen den den scham verloren wobei er wenn viel eins auch gerade im anbetracht der tatsache was
zu dem wirklich ein gutes game gewesen ist da war auch da war schon ultra geschleim angesagt auf
dem event wenn viel fünf habe ich nix von mitgekriegt glaube hat mich auch nicht großartig
interessiert ja und jetzt battlefield 2042 leute es war so ein heftiges geschleim es ist kein
wunder wenn die sich die gleichen leute die alles abfeiern immer einladen dann ist doch kein wunder
dass sie denken sie haben das beste spiel aller zeiten entwickelt die müssten sich tatsächlich
mal leute einladen die ihnen auch sagen was da dran eben für sie nicht gut ist beziehungsweise was
sie verbessern würden bzw vielleicht sogar ein paar vorschläge machen was man verbessern könnte
du brauchst nicht die leute die alles immer scheiße finden und mit kraft ausdrücken um sich werfen ja
auf die leute hätte ich auch kein bock mich als entwickler auseinanderzusetzen aber es gibt ja
auch genug leute die sich tatsächlich wünschen dass ein gutes game wird und wahrscheinlich sogar
für ein apple und ein ei dort mitarbeiten in form von feedback geben und ausprobieren und machen
und tun die wahrscheinlich immer großartig für geld haben wollen ja gibt es genug es juckt
kein das einzige was sie sich einladen sind irgendwelche leute die alles abfeiern weil
ansonsten wäre das ja zu toxic das geht ja nicht wenn irgendjemand sagt das feature im
spiel gefällt mir nicht weil was weiß ich der der respawn da nicht richtig funktioniert das
ist toxic mittlerweile heutzutage toxic das kannst du nicht sagen und dann kommt halt kacke bei raus
willst du machen die wollen nur verkaufen das hat mit battlefield 2042 ja nur zum teil funktioniert
mit battlefield eins hat es gar nicht funktioniert und mit battlefield 2042 ne moment nicht
battlefield eins battlefield fünf moment fünf ja mit battlefield fünf hat es ja gar nicht
funktioniert wo sie von anfang an ihre ihre fans schon geflamed haben hat überhaupt nicht
funktioniert und jetzt battlefield 2042 hat auch nur zum teil funktioniert weil die vorverkaufszahlen
verkaufszahlen am anfang von battlefield 2042 waren wirklich gut weil die haben auch einen super job
gemacht marketing technisch das kannst du wirklich nix nix sagen aber ich gehe davon aus dass selbst
schon nach der ersten woche die verkaufszahlen ins bodenlose gefallen sind ich meine die hatten
teilweise da gab es doch screenshots von leuten oder was für fotos von leuten die die discs
gezeigt haben im mediamarkt und so die irgendwie 12 euro gekostet haben nach zwei wochen und es
gab doch direkt irgendwie auch drei oder vier wochen nach release free weekend und und preis
nachlassen und die wollten unbedingt sagen guck mal wie geil sich das verkauft das verhalt dass
es insgesamt jetzt super erfolgreich ist kann ich mir nicht vorstellen die haben ja mit dem
game nach release nicht wirklich mehr was verdient mit was wollen die da großartig was verdient dass
da leute jetzt wahnsinnig viele microtransactionen und shops drinne kaufen bezweifle ich mal ganz
stark bei battlefield 2042 das was leute wisst ihr was mich nicht wundern würde das was apex
heute in der woche macht oder was apex was apex an einem tag verdient macht battlefield vielleicht
im monat 2042 mit in-game transactions und gedürnt falls überhaupt irgendjemand in-game dort
einsthaft was kauft ich könnte mir tatsächlich vorstellen dass es so größten ordnung sind apex
am tag battlefield im monat so weit sind wir schon aber gut die haben es halt auch einfach
richtig richtig verkackt ja gibt es doch gibt doch jede menge call of duty events wo höchst
wahrscheinlich auch der solution der tricks eingeladen ist ich meine er ist einer größten streamer
mittlerweile in deutschland garantiert gibt es das doch ich meine ich bin ja nicht eingeladen
ich ganz ehrlich ich will da auch nicht hin also ich würde mich an meiner stelle auch auch nicht
einladen und ich würde auch nicht hin wollen das denkt man sich so das finde ich nicht das denkt
man sich weil man kennt man kennt halt man kennt es halt nicht mehr besser aber die müssen halt
was erstellen was ähnlich gut ist dann will man das auch haben wurde nicht eingeladen hätte
eh keinen bock okay da haben wir was gemeinsam ich hätte auch keinen bock auf solche events
so also jetzt ich wollte ich wollte eigentlich warum soll ich meine location schießen amazon
geh weg ich will mal ach so ich habe auch so hier drauf gedrückt oder ich will meine location
nicht nicht schießen hast du inzwischen umsatz generiert mit einer webseite die gibt es doch
gar nicht mehr die gibt es doch schon lange nicht mehr das war mir zu anstrengend den crawler zu
pflegen und zu updaten so leute soll ich mal kurz gucken wie viel geld ich mit dem preis champ
verdient habe keck ich glaube gar nichts ich muss mal kurz gucken warte mal amazon ich weiß gar
nicht ob ich hier ob ich hier login habe login doch doch doch warte mal ich sage es euch ich sage
es euch nee ich kann mich nicht einloggen ich habe das passwort gerade nicht nicht hier
gar nichts also das letzte mal wo ich geguckt habe also ich war vorbei das da lief die seite noch
ich glaube ich habe gar nichts gemacht aber ich habe ja da auch nichts großartiges drinne ich
hatte nur wenn du auf amazon klickst den affiliate link drinne das heißt es muss irgendjemand über
amazon auf diesen f über diesen affiliate link von amazon gegangen sein der nächsten 24 stunden
was gekauft haben glaube ich nicht ich habe wenn überhaupt wenn überhaupt habe ich ein paar senst
damit verdient ich glaube nicht dass wir überhaupt im eurobereich angelangt sind also die seite hat
auf jeden fall mehr gekostet also damit verdient haben das ist nicht schlimm ich hätte auch
weiter laufen lassen wenn das pflegen der crawler nicht so aufwändig gewesen wäre richtig big
storms die können ruhig zugucken wie gesagt ich habe eher mehr verlust gemacht als plus
was ist denn ein heil heiler ein heiler ziehungspfleger
guck mal wie ich meine eigenen videos empfohlen krieg egal ich wollte ja eigentlich was einkaufen
ok fangen wir mal an wie gesagt so viel ist es nicht der ziel der ziel das ziel des stibs
war eh dass wir ein bisschen schwätzen können mal zur abwechslung meinung zum neuen gott ich
habe noch nichts davon gesehen ganz ehrlich ich habe mir bis jetzt auch nichts angeguckt dort
net unter meckos nee habe ich nicht aber das sollte eigentlich wenn du bei den standard
framework sachen bleibst kann kein unterschied machen ja gibt es immer noch wollen wir mal gucken
wobei ich wurde bestimmt ausgelockt mittlerweile
ja kann ich nicht gucken aber wahrscheinlich gibt es keine server mehr ich gehe mal auch
davon aus dass der reality mod nicht so viel gebracht hat an spieler zahlen weiß nicht ob
jemand von euch in letzter zeit mal reingeguckt hat was in wenn es abgeht ich denke der reality
mod hat vielleicht ein server noch mit ein paar spielern drauf
die value stores gibt es doch so ziemlich für alles der desktop ist so muss der desktop aussehen
so also gehen wir mal zu amazon ich muss mal kurz meine shopping liste aufmachen also was
brauchen wir das erinnert mich an was tatsächlich was kostet aktuell was kostet denn an schiel tv
aktuell mein schiel tv gibt nämlich glaube ich den geist auf
nee das wusste ich nicht dass es der standard library eine hat
ganz schön teuer
von wann ist denn das aktuelle modell
doch kein steamed os
Warum kein Chromecast weil Shield TV das beste ist
Allein schon wie weich sich das Ganze gar nicht bedienen lässt
Also ich glaube ich glaube das ist von 2019 also ich brauche vielleicht neues weil mein
Shield TV geht langsam das Geist auf langsam den Geist auf
Das merke ich daran dass sich immer das Netzwerk disconnected
Weiß nicht ob irgendjemand von euch das gleiche Problem schon mal hatte
Also bei mir kommt es einmal die Woche vor dass das Ding ich will das nicht
sharen kann man dieser share button hier weggehen
Der share button bleibt da oben jetzt
Das Netzwerk disconnected sich also einmal die Woche was äußerst nervig ist
Ich habe auch schon alles probiert von Kabel gewechselt bis Kabel drüben gewechselt
Kabel hier drüben hat alles nichts gebracht ich glaube das Ding gibt langsam den Geist
auf
Das Shield ist nicht gut hol dir sowas warum
Das klingt schon mal absolut nicht vertrauenserweckend diese Seite
Das ist mit Sicherheit nicht besser als ein Shield TV
Kann ich mir beim besten Willen nicht vorstellen
Das Shield TV ist die Kombination aus dass es ein vollwertiges Android TV ist
Plus dass es so ziemlich die beste Hardware ist die du haben kannst für so ein Gerät
Also plus das neue Upscaling ja das geht am Ziel vorbei
Es ist ein Android TV Gerät von Nvidia
Und warum also ok
Umut dann erzähl mal was ist der Vorteil davon also was ist der Vorteil von so einem
Ding
Vielleicht arbeitest du ja da als versus versus ein Shield TV
Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht warum das warum das besser ist man kann mal gucken ja
Ich was ist denn was ist denn Android OTT
Allein schon auch die die GPU aus also die Grafikkarte dürfte deutlich besser sein im
Shield TV
Also keine Ahnung warum ich sowas sowas holte
Also wenn schon würde ich mir wahrscheinlich wirklich ein Shield TV holen und gut ist
Das bringt doch überhaupt nichts willst du willst du nicht ernsthaft auf dem Nuc Android
laufen lassen oder
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen da ist auf dem Papier leistungsfähige Hardware leistungsfähigere
Hardware nicht zwangsläufig besser
Wie viel bringt das Upscaling weiß ich nicht weil mein Shield ist keins mit Upscaling
also keins mit dem neuen Upscaling
X86 Android TV da hast du dann wieder das Problem wahrscheinlich das Prime Video und
sowas nicht richtig funktioniert
Nee nee kannst du nicht es muss Android sein ja muss sonst hast du DRM Probleme
Gleicher auf dem Raspberry Pi der Raspberry Pi ist auch ein bisschen zu schwachbrüstig
Ja gut das ist halt wieder komplett anderes Ökosystem
Was ich halt gut finde am Shield TV ist das Ding ist super weich in der Bedienung ist
mega responsive ganz im Gegensatz zu einem Raspberry Pi
Ich hatte ja auch mal eine Weile in Raspberry Pi mit Kodi drauf
Leute das rumgezuckele da vom Interface ist wirklich nicht mal feierlich gewesen
Shield TV ist einfach super weich es ist ein vollständiges Android du kannst quasi
Apps drauf sideloaden und Sachen machen die du willst
Ihr kennt mich ja ich will ja immer ein bisschen Spezialdinger mit treiben
Es gibt alle Apps die man braucht
Bessere Unterstützung für TV ich will den Videostream abspielen
Oder was soll da bessere Unterstützung sein
Ich meine das ist das ist eine Kiste die kommt bei HDMI an Fernseh
Und dann spielst du dort über den TV Headend Server Fernsehaufnahmen ab
Also sprich was soll da besser unterstützt werden
Und der Vorteil von einem Android Gerät ist noch das nächste ist noch
Gerade wenn es das Shield TV ist unter den normalen Store für alles verwenden kannst
Du kannst halt die offiziellen Apps installieren du kannst Netflix installieren
Du kannst Plex falls das manche noch verwenden
Ich persönlich verstehe den Anwendungszweck da nicht so richtig
Aber es gibt viele die das haben
Amazon Video ganzes Zeug kannst du drauf machen
Das ist halt die offizielle Android App von denen
Auf einem offiziell supported Gerät das heißt im Endeffekt du hast keine DRM Probleme
Und nix das funktioniert einfach
Das kannst du nicht auf Raspberry Pi machen
Weil auf dem Raspberry Pi hast du immer DRM Probleme
Und auf x68 Chart wird kriegst kein Android Gerät zum laufen
Also manchmal ist tatsächlich potenziell stärkerer Hardware nicht zwangsläufig besser
In dem was man machen will
Ja Firestick ist auch so ein Ding
Da ruckelts und zuckelts auch
Ok nein nicht so krass wie auf dem Raspberry Pi
Am Vergleich zum Shield TV
Ich weiß was man mit Plex macht aber ich weiß nicht warum man das haben will
Es sei denn man lädt sich permanent über das Usenet oder Torrent Serien runter
Ok dann versteh ich's
Aber die meisten Sachen die ich gucke
An Serien sowas sind irgendwelche Wots von Amazon oder Netflix
Also dementsprechend brauch ich das nicht
Achso ne WLAN verwende ich ja eh nicht für den Shield TV
Also das Shield TV ist schon pock
Und wahrscheinlich wie gesagt wahrscheinlich brauch ich ein neues
Wie ist der Verbrauch keine Ahnung
Keine Ahnung
Ich stell ihn mir jetzt nicht sonderlich hoch vor
Weil es ist im Prinzip die gleiche Hardware drin wie in der Switch
Mehr oder weniger
Also Shield TV hat ja sagen wir mal mehr oder weniger die gleiche Hardware wie die Switch
Hier kann man es vergleichen
Na gut dann zeig mal her
Die Wahl der Profis
Ok
Einfach und elegante Home Bildschirm
Ok das sieht aus wie das Standard Android TV
Wo ist der Vergleich
HDR kann jede normale Box mittlerweile
Was mit dem USB Over the Air TV
Ok da kann man DVB-Thema machen
Wo ist der Vergleich zum Shield Tablet
Bin ich jetzt einfach nur zu blöd zu finden
Achne du meinst ich kann es vergleichen mit dem Shield Tablet
Naja also die Unterstützung für USB Tuner brauche ich nicht
Weil dafür habe ich ja meine Box mit TV Headend
Hey Max welche Programmiersprachen kannst du eigentlich
Tja
Wäre ich mal ein bisschen ordentlicher Leute
Was
Ist das das was ich meine
Ja tatsächlich das ist zwar nicht alles das ist schon ganz schön alt also
Ich kann C-Sharp relativ gut ich kann Ruby relativ gut ich kann Peisen ganz brauchbar
Was man auch letztens im Stream gesehen hat dass ich nicht mehr total reinscheiße was
das angeht
Ich bin zwar nicht stolz drauf aber ich kenne mich mit Bash tatsächlich und Shellscripting
ganz gut aus
C und C++ kriege ich mittlerweile dank Microcontroller gedönnt auch ganz gut hin
Aber ich hasse C++ einfach
Assembler haben wir auch schon gemacht ja da bin ich aber nicht wirklich gut
JavaScript, TypeScript, CSS, HTML, QV, PowerShell sogar ein bisschen PHP, Rust, Go und sonst
noch was wir alles gemacht haben
Also ich kann die meisten Sachen ohne Probleme lesen
Ich könnte auch ein paar Sachen ergänzen aber Bock drauf habe ich nicht
Also wenn du mich jetzt eher nach fragst auf was ich Bock hätte
Bei Programmiersprachen dann eindeutig Sachen in.NET zu machen
Sachen in Ruby gibt es ja mittlerweile nicht mehr nachdem Rails so reingeschissen hat die
letzten Jahre über
.NET, Peisen lasse ich mir auch noch gefallen oder halt JavaScript, CSS, Frontend gedönnt
was ich mittlerweile tatsächlich echt ganz angenehm finde an Sprache
Jahrzehnte gefühlt, die 2000, nein gut Jahrzehnte ist übertrieben
Die ersten Shield-TVs bekommen immer noch, bekommen immer noch Updates
Ich weiß nicht wann es das erste gab 2017
2015, ich glaube die 2015er Shield-TVs bekommen immer noch Updates
Guck mal krass oder
Also das ist wirklich auch so ein Ding davon können sich definitiv ganz viele Hersteller
was abschneiden von der Update-Politik was Nvidia angeht
Also für das Shield-TV bei anderen Sachen vielleicht weniger
Aber da kannst du dich wirklich nicht verschweren sieben Jahre Updates
Wo hast denn das sonst
Gibt es gute Quellen um als Java-Entwickler die Sharp anzuschauen
Puh, eigentlich kannst du mehr oder weniger alles was du für C-Sharp brauchst
Ich würde versuchen ein kleines Beispiel Projekt zu basteln
Also wenn du Java, ganz im Ernst, wer Java kann kommt in C-Sharp relativ schnell rein
Wer C-Sharp kann kommt auch in Java relativ schnell rein oder in viele anderen modernen
Sprachen Du hast halt so ein paar Sachen die anders
sind Die Generics sind komplett anders gemacht
wie in Java Auch das Exception-Handling ist ein bisschen anders als in Java
Aber im Großen und Ganzen, ganz ehrlich, blickst du da eigentlich schon ganz gut durch
Ansonsten, ja es gibt jede Menge Konferenz-Talks, Tutorials auf YouTube
Es gibt auch ein bisschen älteres.net kostenloses C-Sharp Buch
Wo zumindest die Basics noch relevant sind Ich kann dir sagen welche ich habe
Äh übrigens Leute Dieses Thermostat, wollt ihr mal kecken?
Ich Die Akara hatte ein neues Thermostat
Guckt euch das Ding mal an und ihr werdet feststellen
Dieses Thermostat habe ich euch vor ungefähr, vielleicht erinnert sich der eine oder andere
noch, habe ich euch vor zwei Jahren schon gezeigt im Stream
Das ist exakt das gleiche China-Chinesen-Thermostat was ich euch vor zwei Jahren gezeigt habe
im Stream Das ist das Ding was ich mir damals gekauft
habe Vor zwei Jahren, da stand noch nicht Akara
drauf Und das Ding ist Müll gewesen
Zumindest das was ich hatte Vielleicht haben sie die Firmware mittlerweile
verbessert Ich weiß nicht, ich würde das im Leben
nicht kaufen Es ist laut, es verbraucht Batterie, es fuck
Es ist nicht responsive, es meldet sich laufend an Zigbee ab
Vielleicht haben die das mittlerweile alles irgendwie gelöst
Aber ich habe ein Tier-Down-Video dazu gesehen Und es ist immer noch exakt das gleiche
Das gleiche China-Chinesen-Thermostat nur das jetzt Akara drauf steht
Es ist saumäßig laut, wenn der Motor angeht und die Heizung einstellt
Also, ich habe noch kein Thermostat gesehen was regelt, was so laut ist wie das
Ich sag wie das was ich vor zwei Jahren gekauft habe
Aber es ist halt einfach von der Optik und allem nahezu baugleich dazu
Tja, deswegen, wenn das auch nur ansatzweise noch so ist wie vor zwei Jahren
Und es sieht halt genauso aus, sowohl innen als auch außen wie das Akara Ding
Und das ist ja bekannt dafür, dass die China-Chinesen-Dinger oftmals unter gleichem Namen verkauft werden
Vielleicht gibt es die alten Dinge auch noch
Ja, guckt hier, diese Dinger gibt es schon ewig
Die China-Chinesen-Thermostate nur das da jetzt halt noch Akara drauf steht
Und das hier ist Haxi, Hecksee
Steht nicht Akara drauf, ist aber exakt das gleiche
Und dieses Thermostat wird von, von keine Ahnung, 15 verschiedenen Herstellern gekauft
Ich hab damals den Fehler gemacht, ich hab mir auch eins gekauft
Es ist einfach Müll gewesen, es war wirklich richtig großer Müll
Kann ich nicht empfehlen
Ja, das nächste ist, was kann ich empfehlen, ganz ehrlich
Aktuell gar nicht so viel
Was ich an Thermostaten hab, es sind, nach längerer Zeit
Hab ich mich tatsächlich auf die Dinger hier eingeschossen
Die gibt es jetzt mittlerweile neu, sind nicht wirklich besser
Sind aber teurer geworden
Und mittlerweile ist es halt lächerlich teuer geworden, alles
Weil ganz im Ernst, ich hab damals 45 Euro dafür bezahlt
Als ich es einzeln gekauft habe
Und ich glaube sogar eine ganze Ecke, ich glaub 38 oder so nur
Als ich mir mal einen Dreierpack gekauft hab
Leute, ihr müsst euch vorstellen, es ist noch, es ist keine Ahnung
Zwei Jahre her, wo ich das gekauft hab
Das kostet das Doppelte jetzt
Das ist schon heftig
So und die neuen können auch nicht mehr
Sind bloß 15 Euro teurer nochmal
Und es hat ein bisschen anderes Design
Also ganz im Ernst, 79 Euro für einen Thermostat im Leben nicht
Was will Akara dafür haben
Viel zu teuer
Ganz ehrlich, ich seh es nicht, ein Heizungsthermostate für 60 Euro plus
Ganz im Ernst
Aber die Fritz Dinger kann ich dir empfehlen
Das waren 5 Stück für 300 Euro
Also quasi
Ist auch nicht viel billiger
Also die Fritzthermostate kann ich dir empfehlen, wenn du eine Fritzbox hast
Die funktioniert tatsächlich erstaunlich gut
Ich hatte damit noch überhaupt keine Probleme
Die reagieren ein bisschen langsam, weil es halt überdeckt geht
Das heißt, wenn du jetzt auf einschalten drückst
Kann es halt sein, dass es 10 Minuten später erst einschaltet
Was aber, wenn du es automatisch regelt, nicht schlimm ist
Ich hab es bei mir so eingestellt, dass beispielsweise im Winter halt das Wohnzimmer um 19 Uhr angeht
Wenn man um 20 Uhr einer Fernseh gucken will und so
Wenn man das automatisch regelt und nicht von daheim auf den Knopf drücken will
Und dann 5 Minuten später erwartet, dass der Raum warm ist
Kann sie die Fritzthermostate verwenden
Leider ein bisschen teuer
Von dem Akara Ding würde ich Abstand halten
Weil ich ein mehr oder weniger baugleiches Gerät schon vor 2 Jahren mal verwendet hab
Und das war nix
Ganz ehrlich, auch wenn viele Leute quick and dirty Sachen skripten
In Python Shell ist noch mal was ganz anderes
Ich würde das gar nicht so sehr als Konkurrenz sehen
Ist sogar was dran
Also wer wirklich es geschafft hat
In C++ was auf die Reihe zu kriegen
Ohne den ganzen Tag zu kotzen
Und dass der Kram am Ende dann auch ordentlich läuft
Der kommt wahrscheinlich wirklich schnell überall anders rein
Das hat dann plus den Nachteil, dass er danach nie wieder C++ programmieren will
Wenn er mal was gescheites benutzt hat
Woody, danke für den Sub
Danke für die ganzen Subs
Ich hab wieder die Hälfte übersehen
Hier guck mal
Guck mal kurz in mein Creator Dashboard rein
Don't cry so much, danke schön
Huge Subscription
Cdox auch Sub, danke Leute
So einfach ist es tatsächlich nicht sowas selbst zu bauen
Weil das Schwierigste daran ist, dass du das Wireless hinbekommst
Und so Wireless, dass du es mit einer Batterie über annehmbare Zeit verwenden kannst
Also ein ESP Strom sparen zu kriegen in dem Fall ist gar nicht so easy
Für zwei Jahre Batteriebetrieb
Ja kann ich nix zu sagen, die kenn ich nicht
Guck mal doch mal was sowas kostet
Thermostat
Hormatic IP oder das normale
Hübsch ist was anderes, aber das wird mich jetzt gar nicht so sehr stören
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Hormatic und Hormatic IP
Das eine ist Cloud und das andere Lokal
Will man überhaupt was haben was über die Cloud geht
Also der Preis geht auf jeden Fall schon mal voll in Ordnung
Im Vergleich zu den anderen
Zwei bis fünf Wochen
Warum gibt es da schon wieder so komische Extra Würste
Basic
Alter Basic sieht ja noch hässlicher aus als das andere
Das sieht aus wie so ein ICE von vorne
Guck mal
Das ist wie so ein ICE von vorne, so ein alter, so ein erster ICE von
Da hier in dem Display wird normalerweise der Lokführer sitzen
Sieht sehr, finde ich, aussieht aus wie ein ICE
MonkaDB
Hat ja Meta und Threat Unterstützung garantiert nicht
Hormatic ist so ein eigenes, Eigenverwurstung
Genau, mit dem Typ kannst du dann telefonieren wenn du Fragen hast
Ja das ist auch eine gute, gute Idee in Bogen und C++ zu machen
Nee, ESP Now ist was anderes
ESP Now ist dieses ad-hoc Wi-Fi von Espressif
Das macht allerdings den Idle-Verbrauch beziehungsweise den Standby-Verbrauch von einem ESP nicht
geringer
Der Standby-Verbrauch ist ja das was deine Batterie killt
Keck QL
Das müsste mal irgendjemand erfinden, gibt's das schon?
Alter, was noch, was hab ich hier gesucht?
Keck QL, GitHub
Ok, ich weiß nicht was ich hier suche, aber ich guck mir im Stream lieber nicht weiter
ESP Home ist das von Home Assistant, diese Custom-Firmware
So, also, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Ich will keinen Hormatic Thermostat, ich hab nur gerade geguckt
Also, immer ganz einfaches, wir fangen mal mit was einfachem an, weil ansonsten werde
ich heute nie fertig
Ich brauche ein paar Batterien
Das hab ich jetzt eigentlich schon drinne
Ok, genau, also ich brauche ein paar Batterien
Ich brauche nämlich für die Fernbedienung wieder was
Was ist denn hier schön billig?
Also ich kann mir entweder 5 kaufen für 3,29 Euro oder ich kann mir 40 kaufen für 8 Euro
Ja dann weiß ich doch was ich nehme, oder?
Oder?
Oder 50?
Nee, dann 40 ist besser
Das sind nicht wieder aufladbare
Oder?
Nee, die sind nicht wieder aufladbar
Chat, sind die wieder aufladbar?
Nee, oder?
Gibt es die rechargeable?
Werden die irgendwann schlecht?
Na ja, also ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß nicht wie hoch die Selbstentladung ist von den Dingern,
aber wahrscheinlich kannst du die auch nach 5 Jahren noch verwenden
Rechargeable?
Aber Leute, da kosten 4 so viel wie ich 5...
Guck mal, hier kannst du 4 Stück kaufen, bei den anderen kriege ich 100 für den gleichen
Preis
Wie viel ist denn so bei normalen Sachen drinne?
3 Volt, ja das sagt ja nichts aus
Wie viel ist denn da so normalerweise drinne?
Ja das lohnt sich rechargeable, aber nicht
Ich kaufe mir hier irgendwie so einen Pack mal
Hier komm, 20 Stück, gut ist, sind es jetzt 20 oder 40?
20, 40, ja was ist es denn jetzt?
20 oder?
Die China-Chinesen schreiben dann einfach mal 40 hin, obwohl es keine 40 sind
Oder Wilhelm, einfach stark
Wilhelm, einfach stark, können wir auch 50 kaufen für 8 Euro, komm Bam, Wilhelm, gib
ihm
50 Stück, da habe ich die nächsten Jahre ausgesorgt
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen einer Bios-Bat, äh, ich glaube gar keine
Aber der Formfaktor ist der gleiche oder?
50, klar, auf geht's, ups, weiß nicht was ich hier aufgemacht hab's
Oh das ist irgendwas, das stimmt, das sollte, das hat mir mal irgendjemand geschickt im
Stream
Die geheimvolle Polizei von Facebook, das wollten wir uns auch irgendwann mal angucken
Ist Bios sehr, ja
So, 50, 50 Batterien, gut ist
Was ist denn aktuell die größte NVMe SSD, die was bringt, gibt es schon halbwegs gute
erschwingliche, ja ne, gibt es, gibt es schon 4TB?
Na gut, kostet ungefähr als doppelte, das ist noch im Rahmen
4TB NVMe SSD, sowas hätte ich gerne, das wäre nice
8TB, Leute, guckt mal, hier kostet 4TB einfach 200 Euro weniger, was ist denn da der große
Unterschied, ist die Anbindung oder, oder
Es ist, es ist, hat mehr Lanes oder, es ist Gen 4
Aber das nutzt doch eh niemand aus, das nutzt doch eh keiner aus
8TB gibt es auch schon, ja
Okay, okay, wir wollen zwar nicht, falscher Knopf, wir wollen zwar nicht übertreiben,
aber, ne
Dazu hätte ich, dazu hätte ich mal Bitconnect mitmachen müssen
Dann hätte ich mir das jetzt leisten können, oder ich hätte mir kein Auto kaufen dürfen
oder kein, oder kein teures Klo, dann hätte ich mir jetzt eine SSD kaufen können
Aber ganz im Ernst, 1800 Euro, warum hatten die so gute Bewertung, what the fuck
Ah, die gibt es auch in kleiner, ach okay, verstehe
Wie viel kostet die 4TB Variante, immer noch, immer noch sehr, sehr ordentlich, ja
Aber, jetzt mal ernsthaft, was ist an der so geil, dass die so viel teurer ist
Gen 4, ja bleibt die besonders kühl, oder
Sag mal, die Dinger kannst du doch gar nicht ohne Kühler betreiben, oder
Also du kannst die schon ohne Kühler betreiben, aber wahrscheinlich nach 20 Sekunden ist das
Ding am Limit
Blazing Liefer, ist die written in Rust, glaub schon
Zeig mal kurz, C++, Soli Digim, was für ein Ding, Soli Digim, Soli Digim,
Alter wie soll man das überhaupt ausspringen, das war ganz normale Intel SSD
Leute, ich muss mal kurz, ich bin gleich wieder da
Ich beobachte euch im Chat vom Klo aus, also benehmt euch
Wo ist mein Tee, was hast du da, du Bruder, komm von der级 S игр
Fertig, muss gerade mal kurz gucken wie das Wetter ist, weil es sieht draußen ziemlich
gut aus vielleicht gehe ich mich gleich noch mal tatsächlich eine runde bewegen wie das
wetter in hanau ist was die alpen ja das interessiert mich was in den alpen ist hier
guckt mal da ist richtig gut wenn er vielleicht glaube ich noch mal eine runde klar ergeblich
gewitter moment keck weit gewitter gewitter lang ist es kein gutes wetter mehr die gewitter
ober dass das überhaupt noch irgendjemand kennt wie findest du meins ich glaube in meins
war ich noch nie ich überlege gerade ich glaube meins war ich noch nicht also die größeren
sachen hat er mich deutschland durch mannheim stuttgart ulm hamburg berlin münchen frankfurt
hanau fulda dresden leipzig köln also die meisten größeren sachen habe ich durch habe
ich glaube meins war ich noch nie so gehen wir mal zurück nach emerson okay günstige
erschwingliche vier terabyte nvme ssd was ist die günstigste kingston moment ich glaube
da muss ich woanders hin festplatten ssd m2 pc express und jetzt sortieren wir das ganze
einmal preis pro terabyte wow ne ne ne so nicht fuck preis pro terabyte okay das ist
das ist blöd und jetzt sagen wir mal ab wo ist hier ab ab 3,84 okay data die haben die
haben früher immer so billigrahmen gemacht das ui design ist tatsächlich gut ja das
ist zwar oldschool aber ganz im ernst ich finde geitshals ich meine diese okay warte
mal ich war mal kurz die ein ich meine die seite und ja haben die den dark sieben standardmäßig
schon guck mal die sind richtig modern ich meine die seite sieht jetzt vielleicht nicht
super krass web 5.0 ich 2022 aus aber ich finde so muss eine webseite gestaltet sein
für den desktop betrieb ich kann mir vorstellen mobile ist es nicht ganz so geil können wir
mal kurz gucken gut wobei ich glaube mobile gibt es auch halbwegs dann mobile sollte es
vielleicht in der app sein aber das ist gut das ist wirklich gut das ist nicht so die
webseite wo du das gefühl hast eine webseite will eher eine tablet anwendung sein sondern
nicht funktioniert einfach also ich habe da echt auch immer nur gute gute sachen bisher
so erfahrungen machen müssen was geitshals webseiten bedienung angeht was besser als
idealo keine ahnung ich verwende idealo eigentlich so gut wie nie okay günstigste ssd nvme ssd
4 terabyte team group das sind ja sachen habe ich alle noch nie gehört das ist nass ganz
ehrlich ich würde mir wahrscheinlich eine samsung kaufen weil mit denen habe ich immer
gute erfahrungen gemacht das wird aber ganz schön schnell ganz schön teuer haben die
überhaupt welche haben die überhaupt welche die haben bloß die haben bloß zwei terabyte
vier terabyte haben die gar nicht ich habe von team group noch nie was gehört kann das
sein dass samsung gar keiner hat
interessant hätte ich gar nicht gedacht für mich war samsung immer voll mit dabei was
ssd angeht na gut ich will mir keine keine ssd jetzt unmittelbar kaufen ich wollte nur
mal gucken kaufe ich mir erst wenn ich mir neuen rechner kaufe neuen rechner kaufe ich
mir erst wenn es neue grafikkartengeneration und cpu generation gibt und wenn man die auch
wieder kaufen kann so ich brauche paar schrauben wie nennt man ein schrauben weiß jemand wie
man schrauben nennt mit einer spitze sodass man die irgendwo reinschrauben kann so plastik
oder so zum beispiel ich meine ich kann ja wohl schlecht nach schrauben mit spitze suchen
oder holz schrauben holz schrauben ja sowas in der richtung tatsächlich ja aber die haben
wir ein bisschen kleinen kopf selbst schneiden ok selbst schneiden fife hetscher der chat
ist heute wieder hoch intelligent ohne den chat hätte ich gar nicht gewusst aber ich
suchen muss was ist was ist das das ist ein halber nagel was ich damit machen will also
wo mir aufgefallen ist dass ich gar keine habe ist als ich mein nummern schild festschrauben
wollte in so ein plastikteil und ich bräuchte auch öfters mal welche zum beispiel um in
irgendwelche 3d drucke was rein zu schrauben oder um mal an irgendwelchen holzdingern was
festzuschrauben und so warum warum haben die hier unten kein gewinde ist das ist das quasi
nagelt man die da rein ach die sind für blech
das da sieht mir eigentlich ganz sympathisch aus ja sowas sowas in der richtung könne
ich brauchen die sind auch nicht so schwer zu sagen wie schmal die aber wie schmal die
am kopf sind hier da guck mal und wie breit sind die jetzt am kopf
ich weiß nicht da ist nichts dabei was mich so richtig überzeugt gerade das kann auch
ruhig talks sein ist mir eigentlich total egal so was hier sieht doch ganz brauchbar
aus oder aber 100 stück das ist viel zu viel aber wobei die sind klein komm scheiß drauf
beim fertig aus jeden mal sich ewig rum mit irgendwelchen schrauben so und ich brauch
tatsächlich einen ganz ganz billigen acht port switch nein diesmal kommt bei mir auch
kein mikrotik switch hin sondern ich will das billigste haben was es gibt acht port
brauche ich auch nicht für mich sowas da es ist das aller billigste das brauche ich
für das verwandtschaftsverhältnisse ja das brauche ich für die mutter von dem freund
meiner mutter fürs wohnzimmer die wirst du nicht so einfach in kunststoff rein bekommen
rechtlich wie teuer sind zwei vier port switch keine ahnung ich will in acht port switch
eingeregnet gibt es überhaupt noch vier port switch die meistens eher fünf port switch
oder tatsächlich ja fünf fünf die sind teurer guck mal die sind teurer lull nix ebay klein
anzeigen ich will auch nicht managt haben ich will wirklich das aller billigste haben
nicht weil es vom preis unbedingt so super billig sein soll sondern da soll nix managt
werden p.o.e. p.o.l. brauche ich nicht ok leute tp link oder netgear was ist das low
endigste tp link alle da sieht schon richtig richtig räudig schlecht aus oder was hat
was was haben die sonst noch hier acht port ist das überhaupt gigabit sekunde ah gigabit
es gibt doch eigentlich sonst nix mehr züchsel gibt hersteller von den wusste ich gar nicht
mehr dass sie noch leben züchsel es geht noch billiger leute es geht noch billiger
15 euro 100 ambit switch 100 ambit da kommt das muss nicht sein
die bezeichnung ist auch mal wieder absolut nicht sagen
letztendlich kann man da nicht viel falsch machen chat den da oder den flachen den da
delink ok chat bonnie das ding sieht das ding sieht mir schon zu fancy aus monka es kann
es ja noch mal was drauf stellen sowas was den ersten aber von netgear ja was denn jetzt
einmal noch also chat hier netgear wir machen jetzt mal eine umfrage ich will jetzt wissen
was wir haben umfrage ich mache jetzt umfrage was ich nehmen soll ein poll billig switch
netgear tp link also netgear der 19 euro netgear switch oder 19 euro tp link switch
pass auf 50 50 am ende ich will nichts managbares es soll angeschlossen werden und gut ist es
kommt bei einer oma ins wohnzimmer da werde ich nie was managen und die auch nicht wobei
es tatsächlich ganz interessant ist mal zu gucken ok leute tp link
edi max nee habe ich schon habe ich zwar schon mal gehört ok wir gucken jetzt mal
bei geiz als leute wir gucken mal kurz bei geiz hardware wo ist denn sowas netzwerk weil
wir suchen einfach mal switch switches unmanaged fort gigabit acht neun euro neune neunzig
ala tenda das hört sich an wie in die binde nicht nicht wie den switch tender die neue
tendas die komischer switch mit roten port ok keiner wisst ihr was scheiß drauf tp link
so fertig letztendlich nimmt sich das eh überhaupt nichts das sind alles richtige billig switch
Aber ist schon gigabit oder? Ja, alles sehr schön billig billig switch für die oma am start alles gut
105 euro schon tatsächlich sind wir ganz schön schnell wieder hier die kohle zusammen oder was
kostet ihr so viel geld nix kleinteile machen so da
ja klein viel macht auch ich mein leute das ist doch nicht normal was es aktuell
alles kostet oder ich mein ein paar kabel und ein paar batterien 105 euro
das sind amazon basic ganz normale dinger
ist das so warum sind die warum sind die schlechter ok dann sagt mir welche ich nehmen soll cr
10er pack ok also ist das krepp wenn der chat das sagt wir wissen der chat hat bei sowas immer
recht soll ich in 5er pack davon nehmen oder was haben wir dann sonst noch 10er pack davon
der 10er pack ist aber ein bisschen zu teuer weil hier kosten 5 3 und da kostet es 12
ja wenn ich halt hier
ok haben haben die noch ein bisschen mehr 5 ist ein bisschen wenig
5 10 eine
das ist kraftmax das ist wieder was anderes das ist einfach jebait im titel
das ist bestimmt fake das ist bestimmt richtig jebait fake weißt du was komm ist ist doch
wurscht das hält auch ewig der kram
vier stück sogar nur
reicht jetzt mit so kleinen kram halten uns nicht lang auf kommen es ist sogar nur noch
bei 100 euro gibt es eigentlich respire pies wieder zu kaufen aktuell wie sieht das aus
rasp berry pie 4 tatsächlich 2g modell gibt es zu kaufen
vier ganz schön teuer lief
moment lagern müssen wir mal moment wir müssen immer auf lieferbar auf lieferbar stellen das
können sie vergessen alter der scheiß ist ja mal krass teuer aktuell eine güte habe ich
geguckt dass ich da war ich könnte tatsächlich wenn ich meine raspberry pies verkaufen würde
ich würde richtig plus machen aktuell stonks
ich brauche keine cm4 ich brauche aber das ist echt das ist doch nicht normal was kosten
die normalerweise 40 euro oder so das 2 gigabyte modell
das ist das normale 40 euro im treine das ist meine güte überlegt euch mal das kostet
einfach das dreifache das ist schon heftig was kosten die neuen 0 w 2 oder 0 2 w was
kosten die aktuell da hat gar keiner welche lagern ich habe mir damals zwei bestellt zu
release sollte ich vielleicht mal verkaufen jetzt für 800 euro stück
das ist aber echt nicht normal nichts lieferbar gut dass ich mir zwei stück direkt zur release
gekauft habe aber wahnsinn das ist also das ist doch echt nicht normal was sagt eine
aliexpress dazu was was sagen die china chinesen ich meine nicht dass man dort normalerweise
raspberry pies kauft aber ein bisschen ganz schön gestauchtes bild vom gehäuse ja aber
das ist alles möglichen über den raspberry pie der kostet der vorteil vom raspberry
pies finde ich der große vorteil vom raspberry pie also ich finde dass die müll sind die
alternativen das ist genauso wie die gett diese o'troyd dinge oder so die sind von der hardware
vielleicht ganz gut aber der raspberry pie macht es halt einfach es gibt einige es gibt
einige konkurrenzprodukte die von der hardware auch gar nicht schlecht sind das da die sache
ist plus die der raspberry pie ist halt mehr als die hardware du hast super support linux
technisch ja wer da mal sich rumgeschlagen hat mit einem ambient was ist das was ist
das höchstchen für ficken ach das war das ja höchstchen für ficken genau ich erinnere
mich noch letztes mal auf aliexpress waren was wollte ich jetzt sagen genau wenn ich
mal mit einem ambient rumschlagen musste auf irgendeiner o'troyd hardware oder mit irgendwelchen
konkurrenzprodukten der riesen vorteil von raspberry pie ist halt einfach die super linux
unterstützung dass du so viele tutorials und erweiterungs interfaces dafür hast das
ganze raspberry pie ökosystem macht einfach zu mit abstand besten plattform alles andere
ist ziemlich das gefrickel oftmals ja alles müll war vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben
aber es ist halt nicht so einfach und viele wollen in raspberry pie gerade weil es einfach
so ist und die werden mit alternativen wahrscheinlich nicht so glücklich also du weißt du hast gelitten
wenn es bei den china chinesen auch teuer ist und wenn es noch nicht mal china chinesen
nachbauten davon gibt was für dinger also eben sind kleines und das aber auch was sehr
spezielles ein usb 56k modem warum denn usb da fährst du doch wahrscheinlich mit einem
serial auf usb deutlich besser als mit dem usb 56k modem nehmen usb auf serial konverter
es ist so ziemlich das billigste was es gibt und macht da normales modem dran
kann man mit der dreamcast überhaupt noch online ich meine der webservice davon ist
doch wahrscheinlich schon lange abgeschaltet oder gibt es da irgendwelche emulator dinger
die es nachgebaut haben das interessiert mich jetzt das gucke ich jetzt tatsächlich
mal nach chat usb usb 56k modem von ordentlich und ist nicht lieferbar hast du eine fehlen
wlan repeater den man mit laden was du willst den access point oder du willst keinen repeater
du willst den access point wenn ich das so lese oder was willst du bezwecken du willst
access point ja also mesh fähig sind ja die besseren mehr oder weniger alle unify ist
für mich ich mag unify nicht ich kann dir nichts gescheites empfehlen gerade ehrlich
gesagt ich persönlich also die meisten leute würden jetzt sagen hol dir einen unify krempel
die sache ist halt die da brauchst du dann irgendwie noch ein extra management gedöns
führen muss da durch mit drin einarbeiten und was auch immer also das was ich habe
kann ich dir nicht empfehlen weil das erstens relativ teuer ist und zweitens nicht unbedingt
für den heim gebrauch bestimmt ja da musste die dinge aufmachen und dran ist das das macht
doch keiner weiß dass es geht aber es macht doch keiner ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung brauchst
du überhaupt mehr als ein ja wahrscheinlich aber wenn du an zwei stellen also manchmal
denken leute sie brauchen irgendwelches mesh netzwerk und sonstige sachen und brauchen
es gar nicht wenn du an zwei stellen lan kabel hast kannst du einfach zwei access points
anschließen und gut ist gleiche ssd einstellen und fertig da müssen die dinge mich irgendwie
super krass mesh fähig und wlan ablink und alles einfach zwei access points hinstellen
einer auf die seite des hauses einer auf die andere gleiche ssd geben und gut ist stimmt
du hast recht ja das habe ich jetzt auch schon ein paar mal gesehen das hat mich tatsächlich
nur vom sehen her überzeugt aber ich kann halt nichts sagen ob das wirklich was taugt
also das was ich gesehen habe fand ich persönlich relativ gut auch wenn es auf den ersten blick
aussieht wie unify abklatscht aber ohne eine einige der nervigen punkte von unify das klang
das fand ich tatsächlich von dem was ich gesehen habe ganz gut aber wirklich wenn
man daheim nur in excess einen access point braucht da würde ich trotzdem das es gar
nicht mit anfangen ja wenn man wenn man 34 brauche für das ganze grundstück dann sieht
das vielleicht wieder anders aus aber einem access point würdest du ein raspberry pi mit
einer sata erweiterung aufrüsten ja würde ich machen habe ich auch an mehreren stellen
denn mikro sd karten sind nicht so robust wie man das gerne hätte das ist doch keine
schlechte basis oder
ach moment ich muss das ich sollte das ganze mal richtig richtig richtig lesen also was
meinst du mit einer sata erweiterung gibt es gibt es für den raspberry pi irgendwelche
sata aufsätze oder über die gpi aus oder was kannst du doch keine sata machen also
egal usb anschluss reicht usb anschluss reicht also was ich was ich auch bei den meisten meiner
raspberry pies habe ist ich habe entweder usb auf sata anschluss und habe dann die ssd
dran oder ich habe direkt eine usb ssd dran ich persönlich habe den eindruck die normalen
sata ssd funktionieren ein ticken besser weil lustigerweise kommt es mir so vor als ziehen
usb ssd mehr strom als sata ssd mit einem usb adapter was eigentlich komplett bescheuert
ist was eigentlich nicht sein kann aber also es ist ja im endeffekt alles über usb ob
du jetzt usb auf sata hast oder eben direkt eine usb platte die dann wahrscheinlich intern
auch ich weiß es nicht aber ich persönlich habe bessere erfahrungen gemacht mit usb
auf sata adapter und dann sata ssd strom also ja würde ich machen ich würde usb auf sata
controller kam du kannst aber usb usb ssd strom machen das macht keinen großen unterschied
du musst halt bei einer sache darauf achten und zwar der raspberry pie kann nicht so viel
strom über usb liefern wie manche ssds brauchen also wenn du da jetzt den sammeln super schnelle
usb 32 sonst was ssd dran machst ich weiß nicht was ist was hat der raspberry pie für
ein usb der vierer hat er hat der usb 32 schon oder sorry sorry leute jetzt hätte ich jetzt
bin ich fast wieder jetzt bin ich fast wieder in die falle getappt hat der usb 4.0 gen 1
mal 2 gen 2 mal 2 hatte ja also dann kann es sein dass er ein bisschen wenig strom zieht
ein bisschen wenig strom hat ich glaube du kriegst maximal raspberry pie vor
das stimmt nicht oder ok du kannst maximal 1,2 ampere ziehen und dann halt sonst nichts
über usb machen also ich hatte probleme damit ich kann euch das ja mal zeigen ich hatte
eine sandisk ultra usb irgendwas dran ne ne ne ne ssd so ein teil extrem extrem pro also
so ein teil hatte ich dran aber keine aber keine 2 terabyte alter das ist auch so ein
teil hatte ich dran und das hat dazu geführt dass der raspberry pie mir regelmäßig abgekackt
ist und ich habe im log dann auch gesehen dass die festplatte eben nicht nicht stabil
gelaufen ist er ist dann öfters auf read only gegangen weil er übertragungsprobleme
mit der festplatte hatte also da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen der raspberry pie ist
ja nicht so gut geeignet für super schnelle ssd über usb an meinen anderen raspberry
pies habe ich noch etwas ältere usb auf sata adapter die wahrscheinlich schlicht ergreifen
kein usb 3.2 gen 2 mal 2 können und damit kommen die super klar also das kann ich empfehlen
ich finde ich besser als micro sd karten micro sd karten gehen auch aber gerade wenn du
da ein bisschen was ein bisschen mehr drauf schreibst sind micro sd karten auch relativ
schnell am arsch ich kann dir allerdings empfehlen wenn du den speicherplatz von der ssd nicht
brauchst und auch nicht wirklich so viel leistung von der ssd brauchst und auch nicht so viel
schreibvolumen hast wenn du einfach einen raspberry pie betreiben willst der zum größten
teil rumsteht paar sachen ausliefert und nicht permanent drauf schreibt dann nehmen nehmen
die da ist mir bis jetzt auch noch hier so welche samsung endurance pro da ist es mir
auch noch nie was verreckt bisher von micro sds die sind auch nicht schlecht also ich habe
davon einige so siehts aus
das compute modul hat sogar pizzi express ja das habe ich gelesen ich frage mich zwar
immer noch so genau was man damit macht aber es geht halt allein schon deswegen wirds gemacht
ja genau wenn man jetzt das stimmt man braucht einen aktiven usb hab wenn du mehr dran machen
willst und dann wirds wieder ziemlich kabelgewirr
ja aber die meisten leute haben ich fand glaube ich mit dem normalen formfaktor besser
da gibt es fertige gehäuse und auch welche mit guten kühlern beziehungsweise halt wo
das gehäuse kühlt ja muss muss man sich überlegen ich brauche einen zip gateway client
als kleines device um an 11 anzuklemmen zip ne voip und zip ist schwarze magie da habe
ich möglichst wenig mit zu tun so brauche ich noch irgendwas lass mal kurz in meine
liste gucken so viel ist es nämlich gar nicht ok gutes wetter ist schon wieder vorbei leute
hat sich erledigt moin klausi 1305 ich brauche socken ich weiß nicht ob wir socken im stream
kaufen sollen aber ja 43 46 optimal passt socken das haben wir sonst noch wie puma socken
kommen die puma socken sind sogar billiger als die anderen socken aber die haben ja oberweiliger
socken nämlich lieber die socken socken arch user socken genau wie ist das nicht lieferbar
oder was wie keine socken lieferbar nicht das richtig sie sind nicht lieferbar ach
ne color muss ich selecten ja das reicht auch jawoll wieviel ist das 6er pack werden
socken gekauft auf geht's socken moment moment wenn schon wenn schon dann richtig oder gibt
es gibt es gibt es auch weifu socken naja nicht wirklich oder
die koko die socken so haben wir kurz abhaken akkus habe ich amazon basic batterien habe
ich auch socken habe ich auch wie sagt man ich habe mal vor einem jahr oder so gehört
es gibt angeblich ein neues bei dynamics 500 bei mx 300 bald anscheinend ist es ja noch
nicht soweit
gibt mal programmer socks
ich weiß nicht
keine ahnung ich weiß nicht
socken mit home assistant integration ja das stammt das würde ich sofort holen
also in switch haben wir auch ssd haben wir auch geguckt
schrauben haben wir batterien haben wir auch
eine sache wollte ich noch gucken auto 12 volt mehrfach mehrfach stecker oder sowas
kann man da sowas bedenkenlos dran machen weiß ich wie safe sowas ist wahrscheinlich
ist es safe das ist auch so wie viele wie viel usb anschlüsse möchtest du im auto
haben aber wofür ja für future use so nicht ganz klar
war ein punkt operator es könnte auch sein dass die leute die die socken erstellt haben
einfach keine ahnung davon haben was sie da eigentlich machen da gehe ich eher von
aus top deal oral b ja ich habe immer noch meine pro gamer zahnbürste mit bluetooth
und verwende davon eigentlich nichts der smart funktion aber hauptsache damals gekauft
soll ich brauche noch ein usb stick habe ich den das letzte mal gekauft chat ihr habt
mir das letzte mal usb sticks empfohlen und die habe ich gekauft und die fand ich ganz
gut war das die hier
ich muss mal kurz der was auf jeden fall ich muss mal kurz in die amazon app gucken
die sind alle mehr oder weniger trash ja das ist richtig alle massive trash aber ich gucke
trotzdem mal welche das waren weil die fand ich eigentlich ganz ok usb stick sandisk ultra
moment ultra luxe 128 gb
ja ich glaube die sind das sind aber auch teuer warum ist das alles so schweine teuer
geworden ich habe drei stück gekauft für sieht man das oder details
ne macht macht macht euch nichts draus hat ähnlich viel gekostet usb c
waren die usb c ne ne ne die haben beides die haben beides die haben us war das nicht die
mit usb c und usb a das war noch die die beides hatten oder ob die hatten auf beiden seiten
ja genau guck die kannst du so und so verwenden die haben beide anschlüsse das fand ich da
dran eigentlich ganz cool und ich bis jetzt ist mir noch nix verreckt davon und nachdem
ich immer usb sticks verlege und die nicht finden wollte ich mir eigentlich noch mal
aber 20 euro 60 euro komm scheiß drauf manche sagen kann man nicht genug haben in diese
kleinen samsung mache ich nicht ich habe noch einige werbegeschenke usb sticks und die dinger
sind wirklich reutig schlecht die sind bis jetzt immer gut gewesen also die hier bis
jetzt nix nix verreckt von so haben wir sonst noch was zeig mal her usb sticks batterien
hatte ich schon ja eine sache die ich die ich mir eigentlich schon seit seit jahren
holen will ist also aktuell habe ich einen der reutigsten drucker überhaupt das ist
ein multifunktionsgerät der ist an sich ok das problem ist nur das ist ein tintenstrahltrucker
also scanner und sonstige sachen sind ja ganz in ordnung aber man braucht hauptsicht das
ist ein tintenstrahltrucker und leute ich druck vielleicht drei sachen im jahr und jedes mal
wenn ich was drucken will geht das ding nicht und da muss ich düsenreinigung machen ich
habe für den noch fünf sechs verschiedene third party anbieter druckerpatronen aber
die haben dann so ein scheiß eingebaut wie dass du nicht drucken kannst schwarz weiß
wenn die farbpatrone leer ist und sowas ganz ehrlich drucker sind das allerschlimmste
und der allergrößte shit den es gibt was letzte preis ach bei ebay kleiner zeigen kann
ich ja nichts kaufen leute die haben mich ja gebannt keine chance und ich melde mich
da sicherlich nicht nochmal an ich war ja nie angemeldet
die sagen mir nicht warum sie mich gebannt haben also ich wollte mir einen account machen
bei ebay kleiner zeigen ich wollte mir einen account machen bei ebay kleiner zeigen und
dann stand da ich hätte schon einen account mit dieser email adresse wollte ich password
recovery machen und ging nicht dann habe ich an den support geschrieben habe ich gesagt
warum ist warum steht da ich hätte den account habe gar kein account und dann habe ich folgende
antwort bekommen von ebay kleiner zeigen genau wir haben hier genau das ist die meldung
die ich bekommen habe wir haben ihr benutzer wir haben ihr benutzerkonto eingeschränkt
ich hatte gar kein benutzerkonto so
wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt noch mein tweet finden würde wäre natürlich nicht verkehrt
ich kenne jemand der helft ja ja ist klar jebaited so und folgende antwort habe ich
bekommen von ebay kleiner zeigen diese entscheidung ist endgültig wir bitten sie daher abstand
von uns einen blagplatz zu nehmen also ich hatte den account bei euch weitere anfragen
ihrerseits werden wir gerne zur kenntnis nehmen jedoch nicht mehr beantworten
alle was für spasten oder ich habe lediglich gefragt warum das sagt mein benutzerkonto
ist eingeschränkt und ich hatte noch nie ein benutzerkonto jetzt reden sie mit mir als
bin ich irgendwie der übelste verbrecher gewesen alter ich werde mich da auch nie nie anmelden
sage ich euch nie dass das die haben gelitten jetzt ja auch mit ebay hat es ja auch gar
nichts mehr zu tun deswegen bin ich schon lange auf der suche nach einem laserdrucker
was thema laserdrucker ok chat chat sagt den hier das ist auch ein riesen ding für
meine paar seiten pro jahr ist es wahrscheinlich viel zu viel zu hart oder mehr farbe ich auch
noch richtig high end schitt farb laser alter den gab es vor kurzem hier im deal
meine auskunft nach der es gibt das ist eine gute idee chat das ist eine gute idee allein
schon allein schon um die abzufacken muss ich das machen 81 euro da ist doch irgendein
haken dabei oder das ist doch bestimmt dann mit dm auf dem toner oder irgendwie so was
dm auf dem toner irgendwas muss da sein happy color laser jet pro
kost 516 naja ganz im ernst wenn der rest einfach nur top ist ja kannst du nur mit
brother papier benutzen ja ist klar also ich lasse mich ja jebaiten aber so einfach jebaiten
lasse mir auch nicht von wann ist das was wann ist der rausgekommen release
bei hp musst du dich mit einem konto anmelden um zu scannen was alter was ist denn mit den
ganzen hersteller los mensch ist das wirklich so chat
ja drucker ist abartig danke für den sap kann ich gebrauchen jetzt die 5 euro was machen
die was was ist mit den drucker herstellern los warum muss ich in den cloud account erstellen
muss ich bestimmt nicht es gibt auch bestimmt open source treiber mit denen das geht
ja du hast recht mit dem handy ein foto machen geht aber es ist trotzdem ein unterschied
wenn du ein dokument abscans ist es schon schöner als mit dem mit dem handy abfotografiert
ja du hast hp-dinger installiert aber konntest du scannen ohne account
mit fax ganz wichtig mit fax ja geht drucken kopieren scannen faxen
papier man braucht kein original papier oder was office office lens achso das ist so ein
microsoft ding was hat der für einen anschluss hat der netzwerk hat der netzwerk anschluss
netzwerk 5 ja ja ja finde ich gar nicht mal so schlecht der drucker macht öfters faxen
achso ist das gemeint
könnte man sich tatsächlich mal überlegen der drucker leute die was ausdrucken wollen
brauchen drucker ab und zu muss ich noch mal was ausdrucken ich kann mich jetzt gar nicht
dran erinnern was das letzte war ich glaube ausweiskopie in der ausweiskopie war letztens
mal angesagt steuerberater muss ich ja nichts mehr drucken
ich habe letztens eine zecke eingeschickt um sie zu untersuchen untersuchen zu lassen
und da musste man sich ein formular ausdrucken ausfüllen die zecke auf das formular kleben
mit dem tesar streifen und dann den brief umschlagen und los schicken da habe ich mir
auch bin ich mir vorgekommen wie im letzten jahrtausend
ne aber mit dem dhl support hatte ich schon hatte ich schon meinen spaß als mein zoll
als mein paket beim zoll in leipzig gelegen hat und und die die die frau vom dhl support
gesagt hat ja da kann ich ihnen jetzt auch nicht nichts weiterhelfen wo ich mir gedacht
habe ja aber weshalb rufen sie mich denn dann genau an das weiß ich jetzt auch nicht die
war geil alter da wusste ich überhaupt nicht was sache ist
die zecke wurde glaube ich dann auseinander genommen und in einzelne teile zerlegt und
im labor untersucht war aber nix das ist natürlich schlecht jetzt wo wir gerade dabei sind ich
muss mal kurz bei amazon was gucken auf der app und zwar ich habe letztens zwei sachen
zurückgeschickt ja perfekt immerhin dran hat euro refunded kann man sich nicht beschweren
also ich habs getrackt das kam an das machen die bei amazon ja mittlerweile wirklich gut
also du kannst ja bei amazon selbst ausdrucken nicht ausdrucken den qr code auf dem handy
mitnehmen und die scannen das dann bei dhl und machen alles selbst fertig also das muss
man wirklich amazon lassen so sachen haben sie drauf ist nicht ohne grund so dass amazon
so erfolgreich ist so die standard sachen klappen bei amazon einfach problematisch wirds
bei amazon nur wenn irgendwas nicht standard ist dann wirds kompliziert ja das habe ich
auch gelesen gabs da nicht irgendeinen typ der letzten sachen zurückgeschickt hat amazon
und es aufgefüllt hat mit irgendwie mit erde und dann war das paket ungefähr so schwer
und er hat das geld zurückbekommen und hat das produkt behalten also so scam sachen sind
dann ja auch schon fragwürdig ja die amazon seite ist extrem pains champ das gute an der
amazon seite ist die amazon seite funktioniert einfach seit 15 jahren ungefähr gleich und
man hat sich dran gewöhnt und amazon stellt nicht alle furz lang die navigation und die
webseite von ihrem shop um das finde ich persönlich eigentlich ganz gut was eklig ist sind alle
anderen services von amazon also prime musik und prime video und sowas die sind an unübersichtlichkeit
kaum zu überbieten genau das denke ich mir auch wo alter aws ich hab mit aws nicht viel
gemacht aber das was ich vom web interface gesehen habe war nicht war nicht schön ich
muss sagen ganz ehrlich google cloud hat mir vom web interface auch nicht gefallen aws
auch nicht und azure ganz ehrlich eigentlich auch nicht ich muss sagen von allen cloud
lösungen und ja ich weiß ich vergleiche irgendwie äpfel mit bieren von allen cloud
lösungen muss ich sagen ist mir digital ocean und hetzer tatsächlich am liebsten ich weiß
es ist äpfel mit bieren verglichen weil aws und und azure und google um ein vielfaches
mehr funktionen haben aber von also wenn man einfach nur eine vm braucht finde ich das
hetzer web interface wirklich am besten das ist so simpel das kriegt jeder hin digital
ocean finde ich auch gut die haben ein bisschen mehr funktionen da kannst du in manage kubernetes
cluster und gedönst und alles laufen lassen ist aber auch ein gutes web interface azure
ist einfach richtig wir ja adblock funktioniert immer richtig da ist seit ein paar tagen kaputt
hat jemanden funktionieren das hat noch jemanden funktionieren das u blog auf twitch weiß
nicht ob ich das als twitch streamer überhaupt ansprechen sollte weil letztendlich verdiene
ich damit ja auch ein bisschen kohle aber da ich bin ja nicht darauf angewiesen hast
du erfahrung mit mit was leonardo plus usb ich vermute mal dass es irgend so ein micro
controller board rate ich jetzt einfach mal keine ahnung steinadler dankeschön für
uns ab funktioniert das noch
die leute haben teilweise echt dachschaden also gerade was da im cloud umfeld abläuft
da hat jeder so seine eigene vorstellung und nur das und das ist gut ja ich weiß nicht
ich finde gerade was das angeht da wird so viel overengineert auch bei kleinen sachen
ist ja in eine vm hingestellt back end drauf und gut ist das hat alles seine daseinsberechtigung
aber muss nicht mit wie heißt dieses sprichwort auf spatzen schießen mit kanonen auf spatzen
schießen genau zumal wenn du mit kubernetes sachen anfängst das zieht millionen ich
weiß es übertrieben aber es fühlt sich so an wirklich hunderte seit container und projekte
und alles nach sich ja da kommen die ersten an ja machen wir irgendwelche helm dashboards
ach nee machen wir irgendwelche fabio proxys ach nee machen wir irgendwie sonstig du hast
dann deinen kubernetes cluster und für den kubernetes cluster hast du noch mal 30 verschiedene
andere verschiedene sachen die wurden für den wieder jeweils fünf andere verschiedene
sachen braucht um sich untereinander zu managen das ist ein riesen ding mittlerweile genau
secret storage da wird es secrets secrets irgendwelche shared state geschickt leute
das hört das hört gar nicht mehr auf also das du kannst das hat alles eine daseinsberechtigung
aber wenn ich den webser wenn ich eine webseite laufen lassen will wo keine ahnung mein lebenslauf
drauf ist und und paar private folos die ich gemacht habe das muss nicht im kubernetes
cluster laufen
hat die telekom nicht openshift war die telekom war die magenta cloud nicht openshift ich
bilde mir ein irgendwas war da wir haben doch mal bei der telekom irgendwelche cloud stellenanzeigen
geguckt ob shit ich habe mit auf dem schiff noch nie was gemacht keine ahnung ist das
nicht telekom ja ja ach open stack war das open stack nicht openshift
du ist der atlasien ci cd server oder
atlasien hat mittlerweile so viele tools da blick ich auch noch mal durch was die ja ist
es ist es
habe ich noch nie was mitgemacht
man kann container auch wirklich sinnvoll nutzen ja da wird zwar da wird zwar viel auf
veringeniert aber was ich wirklich gut finde ist noch ein bisschen werbung machen für
mein home assistant addon also leute falls einer von euch in halbwegs modern fiat hat
und sein als heim automatisierung home assistant verwendet kann ihr mal mein addon ausprobieren
um so sachen wie batteriestand und reifendruck und sowas in home assistant zu bringen zumindest
das finde ich ist eine gute anwendung gute anwendung für container jedes addon läuft
in einem eigenen container ganz simpel mit einem config file und im docker file du brauchst
kein kubernetes cluster und sonst was simpelste docker file aller Zeiten und ein run script
und fertig ist also das finde ich ist super anwendungsszenario hier dass die addons schön
kapseln kannst voneinander und es halt auch sinn macht container zu verwenden ohne es
gleichermaßen krass zu overingenieren warum will man seinen auto in home assistant einbinden
ja zum beispiel zum beispiel dass du dir so ein dashboard machen kannst da kannst du
dir anzeigen lassen wie viel ladungsgrade hat wie viel du noch fahren kannst was der
lade startet wie lange du bis zur nächsten wartung noch fahren musst fahren kannst wobei
kannst du auch länger fahren wie lang es noch braucht bis zum aufladen wie viel reichweite
du noch im akku hast ob du noch normalen reifendruck hast du kannst gucken wie viel du gefahren
ist und du siehst wo das auto gerade steht ist doch super du kannst so sachen wie klima
und heizung anmachen oder licht an und aus machen gerade klima heizung ist ganz praktisch
wenn du wenn es kalt ist und du willst einfach fünf minuten vorher schon mal anmachen oder
wenn es heißt dass du mit fünf minuten vorher schon mal runterkühlen kannst du machen kannst
du theoretisch machen du kannst entweder so plus minus über daumen gepalt machen weil
du weißt ja ungefähr wieviel kilowatt du geladen hast wieviel kilowattstunden du geladen
hast da kannst du pima daumen sagen ok dann habe ich wahrscheinlich ungefähr auch so
viel aus der steckdose gezogen und dann kannst du es ungefähr ausrechnen oder du brauchst
halt irgendwas was tatsächlich das den stromverbrauch misst was ich bald habe weil ich hab bald
mein ladegerät und da kannst du das komplett mit ausrechnen lassen nee ich bin 538 kilometer
gefahren auf dem trip counter der hat zwei trip counter und seit dem letzten reset von
dem von dem trip counter bin ich 538 kilometer gefahren aber ganz im ernst wahrscheinlich
bin ich tatsächlich nicht mehr damit gefahren bis jetzt wahrscheinlich bin ich sogar weniger
damit gefahren nicht tageszähler das ist bis du reset ist also trip der trip der erste
trip counter ist bis du die reset ist könnte sein dass der zweite trip counter tageszähler
ist ich glaube ich glaube mehr bin ich wirklich nicht gefahren wie der kilometer stand zusammen
kommt ganz einfach das ist ein vorführe auto deswegen war es auch ein bisschen billiger
und die sind halt schon 7000 oder 6000 kilometer gefahren 6800 der resette den nicht nach
jedem ladevorgang nee könnte man aber beispielsweise mit einer automatisierung wahrscheinlich
machen gerade mal schauen in der fiat app wie weit er denn mit laden ist 65 prozent
das kann aber eigentlich nicht sein ich habe den heute morgen angestöpelt ich muss mal
kurz refreshen mal gucken wie weit mein auto gerade mit laden ist kannst du den fern steuern
manche sachen du kannst zum beispiel lichte anmachen oder den kofferraum an und auf machen
perfekt 84 prozent hat er gerade excellent 84 prozent das heißt bis heute abend ist
er voll ein quatsch das geht nicht ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob es überhaupt erlaubt
ist autos anzubieten die remote steuerbar sind und wie steuers den dann hast du dann
kannst du auf dein tablet mit der kamera gucken und dann den steuern damit oder was kann sie
quasi cockpit kamera anzeigen lassen und dann hast du dann so sachen wie vorwärts
rückwärts das ist aber auch nicht ohne wenn du dein auto vom handy aus steuern kannst
weil hast du ganz anderen blickwinkel drauf wie wenn du vorne im auto sitzt also ja mein
cool von der technik her ist das nice ob das ob das am ende dann so gut ausgeht muss ich
zeigen ja bis bis man die customfirma flasht dann geht ab gibt es tesla customfirma wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich schon erstmal auf github leute firma kompilieren
ja gut leute war ein nice stream hat genauso gelaufen wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe
wenig eingekauft und viel geschwätzt aber das musste auch mal wieder sein morgen früh
bin ich am start wie gehabt aufwachen streben wieder so gegen 9 in dem dreh und wir sehen
uns dann bis morgen machts gut zu